So, ich bin noch mal kurz da, wahrscheinlich nicht allzu lang, mal gucken, wobei so was
atet ja immer aus, ich mach dann immer 5 Sachen und dann laber ich 2 Stunden random
zu anderen Sachen.
Wonka Giga, ja so siehts aus.
Ich glaub ich muss mir gleich noch was zu trinken holen, ist fast alles leer.
Ah, kann ich gleich machen, ah exzellent, so, es gibt mal wieder ein paar Sachen die
ich einkaufen muss, will, muss oder wie auch immer man es sieht, da hab ich mir gedacht
ich mach das einfach im Stream, Klopapier hab ich noch, Klopapier hab ich genug, Klopapier
muss ich nicht kaufen, ich hab noch 72 Rollen von der letzten Bestellung, das reicht, brauch
ich kein Klopapier, aber der Chat hat mich heute Morgen wirklich auf eine gute Idee gebracht,
ich hab mal geschaut und wahrscheinlich kann ich wirklich mein Klo ein bisschen smarter
machen, indem ich die Infrarotfernbedienung, die Signale irgendeinem ESP32 oder irgendeinem
anderen Proutlink oder sonst was bei bringe und dann kann ich dann demnächst vom Tablet
aus die Spülung vom Klo betätigen, also die Bob's Spülung, nicht die Klo Spülung an sich.
Ja, Frankfurt und Corona ist RIP, das ist so eine Sache wo ich übrigens nicht so genau
verstehe was mit den Stonksleuten bei uns auf der Arbeit los ist und zwar gerade in Frankfurt
sind die Corona-Zahlen extrem gerade, extrem das ist jetzt keine Peste Mittelalter oder
so, aber ihr wisst was ich meine, ja, oh was, what the f, ah der markiert das Terminal,
ich wollte gerade sagen was hat der für Schmerz, null, zumindest also die Corona-Zahlen in
Frankfurt sind ja schon ordentlich, ich mach mal den ganzen Shit zu vom letzten Mal, jetzt
hab ich aufgefallen dass man Steuerungen wenig mehr gedrückt halten kann im Firefox, warum
auch immer, weil die Leute dann aus Versehen zu viele Tabs zugemacht haben oder so, also
sie... und dann streamen geht noch, ist es in der Forst, what the fuck, he, ok, what the
f, home, was ist mit der Netzwerkkarte, ah guck mal, ist die Netzwerkkarte nicht connected,
doch, was denn jetzt los, bridged, warum, warum, warum hab ich kein, he, wo hab ich kein Internet,
ich hab keine IP, warum hab ich keine IP, warum hab alles in der, he, der ist hier bestimmt
irgendwas nicht richtig connected, also Networkadapter bridged, so wie siehts hier aus, was hab ich
hier in den anderen VMs drinnen, guck mal ob es da funktioniert, DHCP range voll, nee,
das kann nicht sein, moin, woid, Danny, aber warum hab ich kein Internet in meiner VM, was
dann da los, bridged, ok, reboot, reboot, reboot, he, hast du schonmal was mit Rust gemacht,
ja, vor 2, 3 Jahren oder so hab ich mal in Rust ein bisschen was gebastelt, als es neu
war, so, gibts jetzt ne IP, jetzt gibts ne IP, ok, geht alles, exellent, ja, genau, also
die Corona Zeilen in Frankfurt gehen ja gerade durch die Decke, bisschen zur Beruhigung,
mal runter, Aquarium, übrigens wenn ich wirklich diese Videosachen aufnehme für Weihnachten,
da mach ich ein Video komplett nur Ascii-Quarium ins Hintergrund und erzähle irgendwas random,
hab ich mir schon überlegt, einfach weil es total unerwartet kommt, genau, also in Frankfurt
ist das, gehts richtig ab was Corona angeht, deswegen verstehe ich die Stonksleute bei
uns auf der Arbeit nicht, genau, das ist das was ich sagen wollte, hier die Hardcore Stonksleute,
die sind nämlich der Meinung, dass es sinnvoll ist, wenn 50% der Leute noch auf die Arbeit
gehen, also in Frankfurt, so, und ihre Idee ist, dass sich die Leute abwechseln sollen,
also sprich, dass dann alle schön abwechselnd krank werden, also sprich, heute geh ich hin,
morgen geht ein Kollege hin, dann geht wieder ein anderer hin, sodass immer nur die gleichen
Leute zusammen da sind, was aber beschwachsinnig ist, weil, was soll das bringen, außer dass
die sich dann unabhängig, also, hä, das sorgt doch nicht dafür, dass die Leute nicht krank
werden, das sorgt vielleicht dafür, dass der Betrieb auf der Arbeit ein bisschen besser
aufrechterhalten werden kann, ähm, aber, äh, ist gut für die Leute, ist das nicht,
ist T-Max ähnlich wie Screen Yano, dass du mehr machen kannst, äh, kannst du das Aquarium
in Wallpaper Engine hinzufügen, nee, glaube ich nicht, das ist irgendein Pearlscript,
ein uraltes, das wird nicht in Wallpaper Engine funktionieren, so, und, das, das verstehe
ich grad nicht, was mit denen los ist, nee, mich betrifft das nicht, mich betrifft das
nicht, ich, äh, aber trotzdem finde ich die, den Ansatz hier bescheuert, weil gerade in
der Technik können so viele Leute ihre Sachen von der Heimat ledigen, gibt überhaupt keinen
Grund, warum man da sein müsste, die G-Stell, vier Monate, dankeschön, huge subscription,
nice, so, klein Rotti fragt, ah, ich muss noch mal kurz das, äh, den Chat wieder starten,
dass ich dann Sachen mit gelockt hab hier, ja, ich weiß schon, dass es vergessen hat,
dass ich Darkmode hab, guck mal, MonkaS nach links geht, aber nach rechts geht, nicht,
ah, komisch, ja, also, äh, auf die Frage hin, würdest du für einen ESP32 eher Rust
oder C++ nehmen, ist meine Antwort, ganz einfach, äh, C++, weil Rust für einen ESP32 total
unausgegorenes, äh, Test-Alpha-Projekt gerade ist, also, wenn du, wenn du einen ESP32 ernsthaft
programmieren willst, kommst du an C und C++ nicht vorbei, es gibt ein paar Sachen
wie Lua und MicroPython und so, aber, wenn du wirklich das Ding ein bisschen ausreizen
willst und auch die ein oder anderen, äh, ein bisschen abgedrehteren Fälle machen willst,
wie zum Beispiel ein Web-Server mit SSL und so was, der mehr als eine Verbindung schafft,
dann kommst du an C und C++ nicht vorbei.
So, Mark Jojo fragt, Max will gerade von Strato weg, wegen hohen Domainkosten, wie ist noch
mal der billig Domainanbieter, äh, ich hab bei denen, aber, du musst da nicht hin, also,
das lohnt sich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ich würd lieber einen anderen suchen, also, bei
dem bin ich, weil die mal ultra billig waren, aber geh lieber woanders hin, die einen DNS-API
haben.
Die haben nämlich keine API für den DNS und DNS ohne API sackt.
Ja, die haben nämlich keine API, das ist richtig, richtig hängen geblieben.
Kriegen sie auch nicht gebacken, also, ich würd lieber woanders hingehen, was kosten
bei Hetzner oder so, so eine Domain, ich weiß nicht, das wollen sie mir immer aufschwärzen,
wenn ich da ein paar Servern rumklicke, Leute, übrigens, ich hab jetzt mal die Sache befolgt
von euch, ähm, letztens hat doch einer im Stream geschrieben, äh, schau dir mal, äh,
1&1-hosting an, und ich hab das jetzt mal gemacht, ich hab mir jetzt so einen Server
hier gekauft, einen 1-Euro-Server, jetzt passt mal auf, das erste, was dir, was einem
auffällt ist, dass die irgendwie noch nicht so 100%-ig im Cloud-Zeitalter angekommen sind,
denn wenn man sich das hier kaufen will, flow690 abonniert, 12 Monate, dankeschön, huge subscription,
massive, massiv, so, und wenn man jetzt hier ein Euro im Monat, hier, den hab ich mir
gekauft, einfach mal zum Ausprobieren, kostet jetzt 93, äh, 93 Cent, wegen niedriger Mehrwertsteuer,
und wenn man das hier jetzt abschließen möchte, was wird gekauft, Technik, Krams und bisschen
Zeug, was ich verbrauche, Kram und Kram gleich, ich hab's mir aufgeschrieben, so grob, der
Hype-Train ist am Start, Skamars-Train läuft, Leute, so, ähm, zumindest, wenn man das
hier kaufen will, das hier ist alles noch normal, so, bla, bla, ein Euro im Monat, ja, das ist
auch noch normal, so, und das erste, was mir jetzt auffällt, was, 12 Monate Vertragslaufzeit,
Phoenix, 14 Monate, krasser Scheiß, bringt flow690 auch 12 Monate, das ist ja nicht nur
Subscriber, das ist ja schon, dankeschön für die Subs, für was braucht man die DNS-API,
zum Beispiel, wenn du Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate generieren willst, und, äh, mit DNS-Challenge,
dann musst du sonst, ohne DNS-API, musst du jedes Mal bei deinem Hoster ins Web-Interface
geheimes Secret hinterlegen, für jede Domain, die du anfragst, und, äh, oder für jedes
System, wo du anfragst, immer durch Einloggen beim Hoster in die Web-Konsole gehen, ins
Secret hinterlegen, den Zertifikats-Check machen und das Secret wieder löschen, also,
das eigentlich ist nervig, also, ich würd keinen Hoster, der keine DNS-API hat, nehmen,
ich machs mittlerweile so, ich hab zwar bei Pogban die Domains registriert, aber über
Cloudflare mach ich den DNS, ich hab ne ordentliche DNS-API, so, äh, das erste, was ich schon
mache, 12 Monate Vertragslaufzeit, ich mein, ich hab das Ding nicht Cloud genannt, das
war eins und eins selbst, und man muss halt sagen, in Zeiten von sekundengenauer Abrechnung
bei anderen Anbietern, ist jetzt halt, 12 Monate vielleicht, ein bisschen lang, wobei
es für den Preis schon echt in Ordnung ist, so, und das nächste ist, wenn man jetzt auf
die Idee kommt, ich stell mal auf einen Monat um, dann sagen sie Einrichtungsgebühr 10
Euro, also, also, im Prinzip, was die damit eindeutig wollen ist, dass du 12 Monate abschließt,
das ist richtig Boomer-Kram, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das so ne gute Idee ist, bei
eins und eins dazu zu schreiben, weil, wenn man, wenn dann irgendwo steht, bei, dann ist
meistens dieses bei, so ne, so ne Qualitätssiegel, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob eins und eins so
als Qualitätssiegel durchgeht, irgendwo in Deutschland stehen die selber, man kann sich
auch auswählen, wo, wir gucken übrigens mal, was domain kaufen bei eins und eins kostet,
ähm, das ist so ein bisschen so, wie wenn da, äh, früher stand bei netgear powered
bei Cisco und sowas dran, ok, aber ob man jetzt eins und eins so als Qualitätssiegel
nehmen kann, ja, also das fand ich schon echt bisschen affig hier, mit 10 Monate Einrichtungsgebühr,
wie gesagt, bei Hetzner, bei DigitalOcean, überall anders, kannst du sekundengenau
abrechnen, die haben hier auch sowas, die man sekundengenau abrechnen kann, aber die
sind auch, äh, fail, weil dort kostet die, äh, feste IP 5 Euro im Monat, für 5 Euro
im Monat krieg ich schon ne komplette DigitalOcean-VM, mit allem dabei, also das ist schon ziemlich
fail, was kosten, was kosten die Sachen denn so bei, äh, was kosten die Domains denn bei
denen so, also machen wir hier, poggers, poggers.de, gibt's wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man könne
mal gucken, poggers ist bereits, poggers.shop, hätten wir sagen, könnten wir, service,
das Service Poggers, wie darf man, wie darf man sich denn unter einem Service Poggers
vorstellen, poggers online, service poggers.org, ähm, die Domainnamen sind eigentlich in
Ordnung, also die, die Kosten sind okay, gerade, achso, das ist Willkommens, achso, danach,
danach ein Euro im Monat, ah, ich seh schon, ich seh schon, ich seh, also hier unten muss
man gucken, warum kostet poggers.shop mehr als, als die.de Sachen, äh, DigitalOcean
ist richtig teuer, ja, wahrscheinlich weil die schon so lange gibt und ziemlich etabliert
sind, ob das gerechtfertigt ist, das ist fast das Doppelte von hetzen der Kosten, weiß
ich nicht, Ratgears.de, oder Ratjurs.de, ach du große, ach du, was ein Kacke, äh,
also anscheinend ist das hier okay, was die Domains kosten, kann man sich, kann man sich
geben, ähm, wobei ich halt sagen muss, ich hab hier bei diesem billig, billig Hoster,
nicht, nicht Porn, nicht, nicht Porn-Bun, sondern Pork-Bun, so und wenn man da mal sucht
nach Domains, Salami, wenn man da sucht, da kostet halt so ne Domain hier zum Beispiel
nur, äh, Poggenpol.cu, Moment, warum kostet so ne Kacke Domain, die wirklich absolut keine
Sau haben will, 688 plus Transfer, was, was ist Poggenpol, ja guck mal, hier kostet,
hier kostet es im Jahr, hier kostet es im Jahr unter 10€ irgendeine Domain, nehmen
wir mal poggers.house, weil ich hab mir auch mal ein Domain mit.house gekauft, gibt's
nicht, doch, okay, machen wir mal, Kacke www, ja, guck mal, das ist, das ist relativ künstig
die Domains bei denen, also ich würd mal sagen, hier kostet es ungefähr ein Drittel von dem,
was bei 1&1 kostet, wobei man hier halt auch gucken muss, das hier ist eigentlich das interessante,
gar nicht so sehr dieses, dieses Gebate, weil die wissen genau, dass niemand seine Domain,
äh, laufen transferiert, Domains, Domains transferieren ist ein bisschen nervig, da
musst du es erst anlocken bei einem Anbieter, einen Transferrequest schicken und so, ich
mein, das ist kein Ding, aber trotzdem, aber im Prinzip muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen,
es ist vollkommen egal, wo man sich nen Domain holt.
Wie viel kostet eine Porn-Domain, wollen wir mal gucken, was ne Porn-Domain kostet, okay,
gachibuzz, ne, was, was, was könnte man, was könnte man für ne Porn-Domain mal kaufen,
also gachibuzz.org kostet 10€ im Jahr, okay, ähm, gibt es, gibt es gachibuzz.porn? Krass,
die muss ich kaufen, gachibuzz.porn ist noch frei, exzellent, ein Schnapper für 80€,
ein wahrer Schnapper, so, ähm, okay, ähm, was, was, was kann man mal, was, was kostet,
was kostet ein Porn-Domain, did you know that there were tons of really great, es gibt
eine Punkt B, eine Punkt G, okay, was kostet Porn.G, unavailable, ja gut, das hab ich mir
schon fast gedacht, dass das unavailable ist, ähm, chat, ich brauch mal nen Vorschlag,
was ist ne gute, gute Porn-Domain Name, wo man mal sucht, der wahrscheinlich sogar frei
ist, Hypergay, das ist wahrscheinlich, das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich, wobei man weiß
nie, ob das frei ist, ahja, hier, exzellent, 2000€ Hypergay, sehr gut, guter, toller Domain
Name, also für, für 2000€ kann man sich das doch mal gönnen, Hypergay, wie, wie sieht
das, wie sieht das mit magenta.porn aus, magenta.porn, also wenn die Telekom mal irgendwie einsteigen
möchte ins Business, soll ich mal nen Screenshot machen, der Telekom schicken auf Twitter mit
irgendeinem blöden Spruch bei, magenta.porn ist noch frei, sehr gut, das sollt, das, äh,
das sollt man den Telekom mal vorschlagen, wenn die da einsteigen wollen, ja zumindest
wie gesagt, ich wollt euch das bei 1&1 zeigen, wie sinnlos teuer der Kram dann wird, wenn
du es auf 1 Monat runterstellst, hier, hier kostet 12€ und 1 Monat kostet 11€, ich
mein es passt gut zum Telekom Voice Assistant, da sagt man ja auch hallo magenta, und gibt
es magenta.gay, vielleicht, ahja, gibt's auch, eigentlich wäre, ey ohne Scheiß magenta.gay
müsst ich kaufen und ich installier dort einfach nen Forum, wo man sich über failster Telekom
austauschen kann und schalte Werbung wie verrückt, weil ich mein magenta.gay kann sich doch jeder
merken, Stonks, was kostet, was kostet die NoMail nochmal, ich mein das muss jetzt erstmal
wieder reinbringen, 20€ im Jahr, das ist ja nix, 27€, das kann man es schon mal geben,
was ist magenta.fail, was ist det, true name, weiß nicht was das sein soll ehrlich gesagt,
beides gute, beides gute Sachen ja, das sollte man sich mal überlegen, da kommt da die Telekom
macht ihr es nicht, also wenn man einfach eine Farbe copyrighten könnte, da wäre es
ja statt, also wenn die Telekom magenta copyrighten könnte, das wäre ja schon hart, magenta ist
ein Farbname, Apple kann ja auch nicht einfach nur das pure Wort Apple copyrighten oder können
es probieren, sondern nur in Kombination mit ihrem Logo und ihrem Kram dabei, ja copyrighten
können die viel, es kommt halt drauf an, wenn was reinkommt, wie ob der einer zustimmt
in der ganzen Sache, so ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich auf die ganzen NoMail-Serie gekommen
bin, aber die Idee finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, magenta.gay, magenta.fail zu
buchen einfach mal, ja was kostet, kann man die sich bei 1&1 dann auch kaufen, magenta.fail,
ich meine die sollten ja da als letztes was dagegen haben, wenn einer sich ging, 3€,
hier kostet es, guck mal hier kostet es 20€ im Jahr, aber hier kostet es allein auch
schon 39€ im Jahr, ne 36€ im Jahr, was, wie, war das einer von euch, chat wart ihr
das, wart ihr das, allgeblich ist noch frei, wart ihr das chat, chat, oh wie lang dauert
das hier was hinzuzufügen, ich will jetzt magenta.gay kaufen, jetzt ist die Seite down
oder was, lol, ja check out, exellent, nein man kann die noch kaufen, man kann die noch
kaufen, was wollen die von mir, wie man darf die sich nicht einfach, was zum, moment, ich
darf mir nicht einfach magenta.gay kaufen, was soll denn das, guck mal und man tut noch
was für den guten zweck sie donaten irgendwas wenn man sich.gay kauft, achso ich muss einfach
nur bestätigen dass das in ordnung ist, weil ich das gelesen hab, naja was auch immer,
so jetzt kommen wir mal zu erfreulicheren Sachen als magenta.gay, chat, übrigens was
ich heute morgen gesagt hab, also ich hab euch ja heute morgen im stream gefragt wie
man unter android eine pwa startet, also sowas hier, install app, das kann man ja auch, das
kann man ja auf android auch machen, also sprich wenn du unter android bist und gehst
auf eine seite die eine pwa, ich kann nicht kaufen, da muss ich mich ja einloggen mit
paypal neuen account regeln, das machst du halt im stream, man kann das ja auch machen
unter android oder ios, sprich wenn die jeweilige seite eine pwa anbietet, dann kann man die
sich über den browser installieren und auf ein heim homescreen hinzufügen unter android,
sondern morgen war ja die frage, wie schafft man es diese app über einen automatisierungsprogramm
wie tasker automatisch zu starten, ich hab's hinbekommen und wisst ihr wie, übelst, aber
kaufst du die wirklich noch, vielleicht ja, ich find die idee gar nicht mal so übel,
und dann mach ich, dann klatsch ich wirklich irgendeinen forum drauf wo uns die leute
mit telekom auskotzen können, bessere name geht da gar nicht, ja und zumal es keine
.de ist, mach ich da auch kein impressum oder irgendwie sowas hin, so und genau, meine frage
war wie kann ich so eine pwa automatisch starten, wenn ich hier sowas installiert hab, automatisch
starten unter android, wenn ich meinen bildschirm entsperre, also was ich machen will ist, ich
weiß nicht ob es eine home assistant demo online gibt irgendwo, genau, das ist ja die
heim automatisierung software die ich verwende, was ich nicht meine, das ist die offizielle
demo von home assistant, da sind hier auch die boys und grills von home assistant unterwegs
mit gar keinem stockfoto, so und die haben auch eine pwa und die verwende ich unter android,
weil die android app noch ein paar macken hat und auch die kameras bei mir unter android
nicht richtig funktionieren in der app von denen, so und jetzt hab ich halt mir überlegt
ich mach das auf meinem tablet so, wenn ich die app hinzufüge, also wenn ich da in schwachsinn,
wenn ich den bildschirm entsperre, will ich das als erstes, jedes mal wenn ich den bildschirm
entsperre, auf meinem tablet als erstes die heim automatisierung eingeplendet wird, so
und ich will das als pwa starten, weil dann ist der browser im fullscreen und ich hab
hier oben keine adressleiste und so, ich kanns euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil android und
ich kann jetzt mein tablet hier nicht mirron gradgescheit, so und die frage war, wie mach
ich das, wie richte ich es auf dem android tablet ein, dass der automatisch der pwa app
startet, wenn ich meinen bildschirm entsperre, so und jetzt passt mal auf, übelst komplizierter
scheiß, also als erstes hab ich mir erzählt oder hatte ich schon drauf das da, android
automate, damit kann man so automatisierung zusammenklicken, so ein bisschen optisch,
finde ich eigentlich schöner gemacht als wie bei tasker, aber letztendlich ist es egal
welches programm man verwendet, so und dann hab ich mir überlegt, so wie kann ich diese
app starten und dann bin ich auf die glorreiche idee gekommen und pass mal auf jetzt wird
es übelst abgedreht, ich verwende nova launcher auf meinem fire tablet und dieser nova launcher
der muss ja wissen, was er starten muss, wenn ich das icon für diese pwa antippe, deswegen
hab ich gemacht nova launcher export, ja nova launcher export, da gibt es hier so ein export
button, da kann man seine settings exportieren aus dem launcher, da fällt dann ein zip raus,
dieses zip hab ich über einen file manager mit fdp server von android runter kopiert,
hab es entzippt, hab also backup, hab es auf meiner linux kiste das nova launcher backup
entzippt, sieht dann halt einfach wie ein ordner aus, in diesem zip ist eine sqlite
datenbank, das ist jetzt kein witz, also das funktioniert wirklich was ich euch gerade erzählt,
ist eine sqlite datenbank, die hab ich aufgemacht mit dem sqlite explorer, hab mir die tabellen
angeguckt und hab festgestellt, dass in einem der tabellen, die sich favorites nennt, der
eintrag ist für die pwa auf dem homescreen mit welchem intent, android startet ja nichts
direkt, android hat nur intents und damit macht dann android was drauf, dort steht dann
in dieser sqlite datenbank, in der favorites table steht drinnen, welcher intent dafür
verwendet wird, die pwa zu starten, das alleine bringt aber noch gar nichts, weil jetzt ist
die nächste frage, wie krieg ich den intent gestartet, das ist wirklich so ein langes
ding hier, also das ist huge lang, das ist ausgedruckt eine halbe seite lang mit embedded
worlds und alle möglichen, das ist richtig lang, das tippt man nicht einfach mal so ab,
da hab ich festgestellt, ok mit automate allein funktioniert das nicht, weil bis ich hier
den intent rein gebastelt hab in automate, wär schon verkehrt, dann hab ich mich dran
erinnert, ich hab thermux installiert, thermux ist, ob tasker oder automate ist egal, dann
hab ich festgestellt, ich hab ja thermux am start, thermux ist quasi ein commandozellen
environment für android und unter tasker kann man nen ssh server starten und ich konnte
mich vom rechner aus auf mein android tablet verbinden per ssh und dann ein bisschen ausprobieren
und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass man unter tasker am start hat, am start ist quasi, das
ist am start, am launch, gar nicht so sicher, hier, am start ist die sache wo man hier mit
unter android sachen starten kann, so, dann hab ich rausgesucht, rausgefunden oder versucht
rauszufinden wie ich mit am start ein intent bei android absetze was meine pwa startet,
es war gar nicht so einfach, weil ich konnte nicht einfach hier sowas da reinschreiben,
ich musste sowas hier reinschreiben, genau, also ich konnte nicht das hier machen, was
die in dem beispiel zeigen, in dem beispiel zeigen die nämlich wie man direkt sachen startet,
am start, dann hier dieses package und der android hat jedes paket was installiert, hat
nen unic name und dann gibt es hier drin so aktivitäten die man starten kann, zum beispiel
hat der firefox eine aktivität die sich launch activity oder so nennt, damit kann man dann
quasi den firefox oder irgendeinen browser starten und dem was übergeben, so, so funktioniert
das aber nicht, weil mein intent viel zu lang ist, mein intent sah eher ungefähr so aus,
so ungefähr sah mein intent aus hier, so wie dem sah ein intent, nur mein intent sah,
also die sache zum pwa starten war 50 mal so lang wie das hier, dann hab ich festgestellt
wenn ich das hier nehme und in thermux reinkopiere ssh, dann, also angepasst mit meinem intent
drinne, dann startet er tatsächlich die pwa und es funktioniert, so das problem ist jetzt
nur noch gewesen, wie schaffe ich es aus automate nen thermux shell befehl abzusetzen, automate
kann zwar nen shell befehl ausführen aber ich hab's versucht copy paste rein hat nicht
funktioniert, dann hab ich mir als nächstes überlegt wie kann man automate dazu überreden
dass er tasker code ausführt und dazu hab ich gefunden, automate dazu überreden, dass
man nen script in thermux starten kann, dazu hab ich nen plugin gefunden, nämlich ein
tasker thermux, wie auch immer, das da, allerdings ist automate mit tasker plugins kompatibel,
das bedeutet, ich kann das thermux tasker plugin in automate verwenden und dort kann
man dann auswählen, hier launch ein script, dann hab ich ein kleines bash script gemacht,
eine zeile, wo dieser intent hier drinne steht, so und das hab ich dann alles miteinander
verknüpft und was jetzt passiert ist, wenn ich den bildschirm entsperre, dann löst die
intent automatisierung, löst über thermux das script aus, was den intent zum starten
der pwa an android schickt und jetzt funktioniert's, alles klar, konnte man mir folgen, so der
kumpermann ist 11 monate dabei, dankeschön und tarrox auch, ja nice, huge subs, alle
nur beide, big brain subscriptions, kommt das in der prüfung dran, kommt drauf an, wo du
prüfung machst, wenn du bei google ne android-zertifizierung machst vielleicht, ja also sprich, das ist
übelst big brain hier um die ecke, wie das funktioniert, hätte das über bash auch bei
tasker funktioniert, jaja, letztendlich ist das ja ein tasker plugin, also das ist ja
eigentlich hier, das ist ja ein tasker plugin, ob du das jetzt in automate oder tasker machst
ist egal, aber tasker ist ein bisschen schwierig zu installieren, die aktuelle version, weil
ich hab ein custom geflashtes fire oder ein ziemlich, ziemlich deep loaded das fire hd
tablet ohne google store und ohne google store und account kann man kein tasker mehr ordentlich
installieren, ja so, soweit, soweit so gut, also übelst kompliziert, aber wenn ich mein
tablet jetzt entsperre, kriege ich als erstes angezeigt die heimautomatisierungsapp, was
unglaublich praktisch ist, weil zum beispiel, immer wenn ich aufs klo gehe und mein tablet
liegt irgendwo in der nähe, schnapp ich mir mein tablet und nehm es mit aufs klo, weil
ich lieber auf meinem tablet irgendwas lese, während ich da gerade am hocken bin, wie
aufm handy oder wie aufm smartphone, so und das gute ist, dann lege ich das tablet vor
mich, entsperre es, kriege meine heimautomatisierung und kann dann entweder den heizlüfter anmachen,
vielleicht die heizung hochfahren oder irgendwas anderes machen, ja weil dann sitze ich aufm
klo und hab festgestellt, ah mir ist zu kalt, dann mach ich dann mit einem knopfdruck bei
meiner heimautomatisierung den heizlüfter im bad an, exellent, so siehts aus, was ist
ein guter android phone hersteller, der nicht zu viele daten zieht, keine ahnung, am besten
sind eh die dinger, die man selbst flashen kann, wo es irgendwelche guten, offiziellen
alternativ roms gibt, also nicht offiziell vom hersteller, aber vom projekt, von dem
jeweiligen projekt offiziell unterstützt das android oder eh offiziell unterstützt
das smartphone, tja, so jetzt haben wir das abgefackelt, jetzt hab ich euch erklärt,
wie ich das mit der pva gemacht hab, voll durch die brust ins auge, das funktioniert
sogar halbwegs schnell, hat nur 1-2 sekunden verzögung beim angehen, vielleicht mach ich
es noch irgendwie ein bisschen anders, aber das funktioniert jetzt erstmal, so und jetzt
kommen wir zum eigentlichen punkt, ich wollte ein paar sachen einkaufen, was mir grad noch
einfällt ist, was gibt es eigentlich, gibt es mittlerweile neue fritzboxen, weil ich möchte
ja immer noch, moment fritz.box ist allen ernst, das taucht in der google suche auf,
warum taucht fritz.box in der google suche aus, das ist noch nichtmal eine gültige domain,
oder doch eine gültige domain, aber da gibt es doch nichts, warum taucht das in der google
suche aus, wahrscheinlich weil so viele noobs danach suchen, wahrscheinlich suchen die leute
in der google leiste oben, lehrzeichen fritz.box und kommen dann da raus, doch wahrscheinlich
das ist für die noobs gemacht ja, wobei das beste feature von google ist ja immer noch,
das ist unglaublich bescheuert, ok twice kann das nicht, ne 20 times kanns auch nicht, ne
es kann nur einmal rollen, fritz.box, oh ne hör auf mir wirds schlecht, so genau ich wollte
nämlich mal gucken, was gibt es, gibt es mittlerweile neue fritz.boxen, weil ich will
ja schon ne ganze zeit meine unity media box, ich hab ja aktuell 2 sachen, ich hab ne unity
media router und ich hab ne billige fritz.box für decked und zip, voip gedöns, die macht
eigentlich nix anderes wie voip die fritz.box, so und ich spiele schon seit längerer zeit
mit dem gedanken, mir ne kabel fritz.box zu kaufen und mein unity media router und die
fritz.box quasi in einem gerät da zu vereinen, ich glaube es gibt nix neues, ne ne das sind
die alten, die kenn ich schon alle, was ist der unterschied zwischen 6 6 0, das ist 4
mal gigabit und das ist einmal 2,5, ja ok das brauch ich net, hier hinten ist die zahlgröße
und dafür ist die zahlgröße, das sagt mir, ich hab jetzt ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
was da der unterschied ist, die macht nen moderneren, aber die hat nur usb 2, wisst
ihr warum, wisst ihr warum, ich hab, wisst ihr was, ich glaub intern ist das alles an
irgendwie dem gleichen IO angebunden und die, dadurch dass die nen 2,5 g laden haben,
die keinen platz mehr nen usb 3 anzubinden, kann das sein, ich mein letztendlich ist netzwerk
und usb was komplett unterschiedliches, aber wenn das lowlevel über die gleichen anschlüsse
mit ner gewissen bandbreite irgendwie drüber muss, dann kann das sogar sein, dass das damit
was zu tun hat, ja gut die kenn ich schon, das muss nicht sein, die waren mir glaub ich
auch zu teuer für das, dass ich nur ein bisschen geld spare am strom von der immunity media
ding, usb 3 verringert oft auch die wlan reichweite, echt, ist das auf irgendeiner
englischen frequenz, kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass wlan usb sich irgendwie stören,
ich hab die fritzbox nur für dekt, nur für voip, nur für voip und dekt habe ich die
fritzbox, haben wir ansonsten, aber es gibt ja nur die 2 cable, was, 649, ist das die
alte, die gibt es wieder, ah, nee ich brauch das da, ich brauch das da, weil vielleicht
upgrade ich ja demnächst zu gigabit, außerdem macht es preislich jetzt nicht so den wahnsinnsunterschied,
nee, dann lass ich erstmal so wie es ist, ich lass erstmal so wie es ist, es funktioniert
ja, ich würde halt gerne die, was weiß ich, 10 watt was dieses unity media kabelmodan
braucht sparen, aber dafür, also ich mein, preislich lohnt sich das nicht, da muss ich
ganz schön lang sparen, dass ich da das geld für die fritzbox wieder reinkriege, nee das
lohnt sich nicht, 5 euro im monat, nee das mach ich nicht, da muss man ja im zweifelsfall
die fritzbox zurückgeben, wenn man den vertrag kündigt oder so, braucht denn so eine fritzbox,
ich weiß es nicht, aber ich würd mal auch auf irgendwie, je nachdem wie sie ausgelastet
ist und was für features du verwendest, würde ich mal zwischen 5 und 15 watt tippen, ich
hab's nie nachgemessen, je nachdem was man verwendet, ja, durchschnittliche power consumption
ist 9,3 watts, ja da war ich doch gar nicht so verkehrt, ist eigentlich relativ viel was
so ne fritzbox zieht, da hab ich das mal überlegt, dass du für weniger ne low power x86 lösung
betreiben kannst, gibt's nicht bessere router, doch es gibt deutlich bessere router, als
die fritzbox, aber ich verwende die fritzbox ja nicht, weil ich einen guten router will,
sondern weil ich was will, was voib deckt und einen kabelmodem hat, und das gibt's
in kombination so gut eigentlich nur bei der fritzbox, scharf drauf bin ich ja nett, aber
gibt ja nicht viel anderes, und voib will man nicht selber machen, definitiv nicht,
also bevor ich anfange irgendwelche zip voib geschichten selbst zu machen, dann geb ich
lieber 52 euro für die fritzbox aus, voib und gerade zip ist wirklich ausgeburt der
hölle, wer sich das ausgedacht hat, ist komplett nicht von dieser welt, so aber jetzt schauen
wir mal jetzt, gucken wir mal was, was hab ich eigentlich alles im wahren korb noch drin
liegen vom letzten mal, einfach voib software auf den rechner, es geht doch nicht um den
zip klein, es geht um den zip server, das was die fritzbox macht, die fritzbox ist ja
reiner zip, also kein zip client, sondern die fritzbox macht ja quasi deckt, voib, zipgedöns,
server, und das willst du nicht selber machen, das ist wirklich hochgradig abartig, was ist
denn deine empfehlung für den router, bräuchte ihn in der dreieinhalb zimmer wg mit meinem
kollegen sind beides gamer informatik studierenden, ja router für was, was soll der machen, soll
der einfach nur richtig gut routen können, ohne irgendwie andere sparenz, also ohne anschlüsse
für telefone, ohne dsl modem, ohne kabel modem, einfach nur routen, dann kannst du
mit den dinger vom mikrotik eigentlich nicht viel verkehrt machen, aber du willst wahrscheinlich
mehr, nur routen soll der, der soll also keine einwahl ins internet machen, der soll also
kein ppoe, kein dsl modem, kein kabel modem, nichts machen, also wirklich nur routen, also
wenn du wirklich was, wenn du was haben willst, äh doch, ja siehste, siehste, sag ich doch,
ne, da hört es nämlich schon wieder auf, in der kombination gibt es nicht so viele,
mikrotik hat richtig gute router, aber so multifunktionsgeräte ist ohne miss die fritzbox nicht schlecht,
äh nein, ich hab mir weder 3 cx noch 3 bpx noch sonst was angeschaut, ähm, ich werde
definitiv kein zip oder voibgedöns von hand machen, zumal ja noch die ganze deck basis
station field, die die fritzbox auch noch hat, ich werd niemals damit anfangen irgendwelche
asterix oder sonstige geschichten von hand zu basteln, das was ich bisher davon gesehen
hab, ist so unglaublich oldschool und beschissen, da ist, äh, usb, da ist der usb 4 standard
noch geil dagegen, also das geb ich mir echt nicht, so was hab ich denn jetzt im, im waren
koppligen, hab ich das schon alles gekauft, die hab ich nicht gekauft, brauch ich nicht,
ich hab mir das jetzt überlegt, totaler schwachsinn, dass ich mir usb sticks kaufen wollte, ähm,
weil ich hab hier noch meine alten ssd's und meine alten ssd's mit sata auf usb adapter
sind viel besser als irgendwelche usb sticks und ich hab die usb sticks ja nicht zum mitnehmen
gebraucht, sondern für irgendwelche basteleien hier, also die brauch ich nicht, die hab ich
bestellt, ich hab allerdings nicht die hier bestellt, sondern ich hab die elektri, elektriker
variante bestellt, ich glaub die hier, exzellent, so, ähm, hab ich auch bestellt, äh toaster
hab ich auch bestellt, aber nicht den hier, sondern einen anderen, die hab ich bestellt,
die sind richtig geil die dinger, ich muss das, ich muss es euch noch mal zeigen, weil
für alle leute mit nem 3d drucker, die die dinger nicht kennen, das ist extremer poggers
diese dinger, wirklich, also stellt euch, stellt euch poggers vor, mal zwei so dass
es koggers wird und das sind die dinger, passt mal auf hier, damit kann man nämlich schrauben
in 3d drucke rein machen, guckt euch das mal an, äh, nein, pass mal auf, ich zeig euch
mal wie das aussieht, hier, hier guckt mal, ran machen, lötkolben holen und dann, guckt,
lötkolben reinhalten und reinschmelzen, so, und danach kann man schrauben in die, in,
wenn das drinne ist, kann man schrauben reinhalten und das ist wirklich bombenfest das zeug,
das siehst du nicht einfach noch, das ist wirklich bombenfest und das ist, was halt
das geile daran ist, die, das erste was ausleiert, bei so 3d drucken, wenn du was hast zum schrauben
ist halt, du machst die schraube eins, zwei mal raus und sie geht nicht mehr, weil das
material ist dafür gar nicht ausgelegt, guckt jetzt zeigt ihr hier, ist das müll und jetzt
macht das hoffentlich danach mit der, äh, was zum, will das nicht einfach mal zeigen
wie er da was reinschraubt, zeig doch einfach mal wie du ne schraube ran machst, ja, ne,
ja, das ist so geil, wie sich das da, guck mal, der testet sogar wie viel es aushält,
ey, wie gesagt, ich hab's ausprobiert, das ist bomben, bombenfest, guck mal hier, was
war denn jetzt in dieser, Moment, pull, outload, 180 Kilo, musste der da dranhängen, dass das
rausgeht, the fuck, 180 Kilo, also glaubt mir leute, die dinge sitzen bombenfest, ähm,
was für ein print, ich hab ein, den da, den da hab ich, wieso kein prusher, weil ich
keinen bock hab 1000 Euro auszugeben versus, äh, 200, der große, also ich mein die prusher
dinger sind deutlich angenehmer, die haben automatisches battle leveling, automatischen
entfernungsmesser und sowas, die technik ist aber die gleiche, aber ganz ehrlich, also
die 800 Euro, kommt man sich sparen, wie findest du den ansatz vom snapmaker 2.0, gar nicht,
ich kenn mich mit 3d druckern nicht wirklich gut aus, kenn ich nicht, hab ich nicht, hab
ich nicht verfolgt, kenn ich gar nicht, weiß nicht, was das ist, oh das ist denn so ein
cnc ding oder was ist das, ne, hä, 3d printer mit nem bohrer, was soll denn das sein, ach
da kann man den kopf austauschen oder wie, oh das ist big brain, der kann cnc 3d und
lasern, moment, ja ja, oh das ist cool, ey das find ich richtig, richtig nice, was kostet
denn das, kostet, wow, ok, ist schon ein bisschen teurer, aber die technik, das ist cool, das
hat was, eigentlich viel viel viel zu teuer, als dass ich es mir kaufen sollte, weil die
Sache ist halt die, oh das ist die größte oder, das ist die größte 1.50, oh mini, mini
cup, das ist die mini variante, ok, das ist eine coole sache.
Cool ist es, aber das ist so ein typisches ding, was ich mir kaufen würde, weil ich die
technik geil finde und ich verwende es nicht, also ich benutze meinen 3d strucker schon relativ
selten, wann werde ich dann erstmal laser edge gedöns und cnc sachen verwenden, gar
nicht, einmal im jahr oder so, wenns hochkommt, dafür lohnt sich das nicht, das ist teuer,
so also hab ich auch gekauft, pass, verlängerung kabel hab ich auch gekauft, die hab ich mir
jetzt auch gekauft letztens, die brauch ich tatsächlich nur und die wasserware hab ich
auch gekauft, ok passt, also exzellent, dann legen wir mal los, das erste was ich brauche
ist, wo hab ich meine liste, das erste was ich brauche ist, ich will endlich mal meine
ganzen shellys verbauen, ich hab noch so viele die ich nicht verbaut hab, hab ich übrigens
hier hab ich mir schon vorbestellt, 5 stück von den neun, kommt irgendwann im november,
die kann man also jetzt wohlgemerkt, obacht wenn ich irgendwelche elektriker elektronik
sachen erzähle, das kann auch einfach schlicht und ergreifend falsch machen, da bin ich
wirklich nicht der fachmann drin, aber ich hab ne ganze menge mir mal an shelly 1 gekauft,
das ist, das hab ich jetzt schon öfters im stream gezeigt, das sind relays, wlan relays
oder auf deutsch wlan schalter, ich benutze mqtt für fast alles was da irgendwie so wlan,
iot kreucht und fleucht ja und das sind quasi wlan schalter, die man unter die unter den
schon bestehenden wlan schalter machen kann, also es gibt ein ziemlich gutes video wie
man das ganze verbaut, shelly setup von irgendeinem deutsch, sogar in deutsch, hier, das da genau,
wo gehts los, hier zeigt das ganz gut, so und was man jetzt hier sieht ist, dass sich die
alten shellys eigentlich wirklich gut nur eignen, wenn man ne steckdose hat und da drüber
den lichtschalter, also so siehts normalerweise aus, steckdose lichtschalter hab ich glücklicherweise
an den meisten sachen, weil die sache ist so, die normalen shellys, die brauchen wie
gesagt alles mit vorsicht zu genießen, was ich hier zu irgendwelche elektronik sachen
erzähle, die normalen shellys brauchen, was ist denn neutral auf deutsch, neutral, null,
keine ahnung, also du brauchst quasi einmal strom rein, strom raus und irgendwie neutral
oder null leiter, also du brauchst 3 sachen, das hast du bei den normalen schalter nicht,
deswegen, also anschließend tut man das, wobei ich zeig es einfach mal im video, wie
man das hier, so, strom rein, strom raus, da hat der flo recht, das stimmt schonmal nicht,
das ist ja wechselspannung, das bedeutet ja, es geht hin und her und nicht rein und raus,
ja, aber wie nennt man das denn dann, wenn man es nicht plus und minus nennt, die amis
sagen im video immer live, so zumindest der anschluss vom shelly mit der steckdose ist
halt, du hast an so einer normalen schalter kein null leiter, hab ich jetzt gelernt, heißt
das auf deutsch, ok, deswegen macht er das hier aus der steckdose, ich machs über mqtt,
aber wie gesagt, ich hab immer schiss davor, hier an so stromsachen rum zu wurschteln,
die sache ist bloß nie, wenn ich das raus mache, ist kein ding, deswegen hab ich jetzt
noch gar keine shellys großartig verbaut, ich hab hier was zum ausprobieren am start,
deswegen weiß ich, dass die dinge an sich super sind, aber ich wollt jetzt mal endlich
mehr verbauen, so und das schöne, vielleicht soll ich erst nochmal erklären, was der vorteil
von so nem unterputz relay ist, also wenn man normalerweise hier nen schalter hat, und
da kann man das licht über schalter schalten, der vorteil von den shellys ist, nein ich
muss anders anfangen, also wenn man smart home geschichten macht, dann fangen viele
leute damit an, sie kaufen sich quasi wlan led lampen, die man an und ausschalten kann,
das problem ist nur, dass wenn man nen richtigen schalter an der wand hat und wlan led lampen,
dass sobald der schalter ausgeschaltet wird, die wlan lampen nicht mehr schaltbar sind,
weil ja der strom zur wlan lampe unterbrochen ist, deswegen ist der bessere ansatz das ein
und ausschalten nicht über die wlan lampe zu machen, sondern weiterhin über diesen
schalter, aber der nachteil davon ist, den schalter, den kann man ja nicht über seinen
smart home schalten, deswegen gibt es sowas wie nen shelly, den stöpselt man quasi ganz
billig gesagt dazwischen, du stöpselst quasi nen shelly zwischen den schalter und die
lampe, was nicht wirklich so ist, aber so kann man sichs ganz gut vorstellen, und dann kannst
du mit dem schalter schalten die lampe und mit dem shelly die lampe schalten, in wirklichkeit
ist es so, du schaltest mit dem schalter nicht mehr die lampe, du schaltest mit dem schalter
den shelly und der shelly schaltet die lampe, und der shelly der kann halt übers wlan geschaltet
werden und mit dem schalter geschaltet werden, das heißt der schalter an der wand funktioniert
noch und du kannst über deine home automatisierung übers wlan die lampe ein und ausschalten,
was viel besser ist, als das über irgendwelche wlan lampen zu machen, gibt es das auch für
die musik wie keine ahnung, so und der typ hier zeigt wie das funktioniert, hier ist so
ein oldschool, also das hier oben ist das schalter, das da unten ist die steckdose,
und genau jetzt zeigt das hier, das ist die steckdose, ja die elektronikprofis müssen
wir jetzt helfen und zwar, wenn ich misst erzähle, müsst ihr mir das gleich sagen,
man hat, also das hier ist auf jeden fall schonmal das innere aus der steckdose, was
ist was, das ist 0 oder, ist das blaue 0, ich habe keinen schimmer ehrlich gesagt, steht
bestimmt drauf, steht bestimmt drauf, aber es gibt auch bestimmt standardfarben oder
so, blau ist 0, das hier ist erdung, ja demmul, das klingt logisch ja, so und hier halt ok,
es ist nicht, das stimmt nicht, wenn ich sage strom rein strom raus, es ist ja bei wechselspannung
dann eher so, dass strom hin und her geht im vergleich zu dc, aber man könnte es glaube
ich schon mit strom rein strom raus umschreiben oder, das ist das was auf so einem normalen,
was auf so einem normalen schaltplan mit plus und null steht, plus bei ac gibt es ja kein
plus und null, so, also das hier ist, ich sag jetzt mal so wie ich mir das am besten
erklären kann, das hier ist strom rein strom raus, das hier ist erdung und das hier ist
nullleiter, was ist denn eigentlich der unterschied, also das muss mir jetzt auch nochmal einer
erklären, warum gibt es denn beides, was ist die aufgabe von einem nullleiter und was
ist die aufgabe von einer erdung, warum braucht man beides, bei ac gibt es kein plus und minus,
nee theoretisch, also von der idee her nicht oder, deswegen ist ja auch bei dc wichtig,
dass du es richtig rum anschließt und bei ac ist es ja auch egal wie rum du es anschließt,
aha, aha, über den nullleiter wird der strom zurückgeführt, aha, ja aber dann warum brauche
ich dann zwei, warum brauche ich dann zweimal schwarz, den zweiten schwarzen gibt es nur
wegen dem schalter, du brauchst das eigentlich nicht, also ist in wirklichkeit schwarz strom
rein und blau strom raus, so eine erdung ist für was da, wenn der blitz einschlägt oder
was, ok der zweite schwarze geht zum schalter hoch oder so, ach erdung ist weil es einen
kurzschluss gibt, ah ja ok, das ergibt sinn, das ergibt sinn, deswegen ich sag ja wenn
ich irgendwelche elektronik sachen erzähle dann ist das wirklich sehr mit vorsicht zu
genießen, da hab ich gar kein plan von, zumindest wie der das anschließt, das video erklärt
das wirklich gut, du musst den shelly anschließen, wo zeigt das hier am ende, hier, genau also
man muss das folgendermaßen anschließen, man nimmt hier zweimal nullleiter, also der
eine kommt wahrscheinlich aus dem keller oder so, einmal hier drangeschleckt verlängern
auf den shelly, dann musst du das quasi strom rein, einmal forken, wie nennt man das, multiplexen,
ne verdoppeln, verdreifachen, einmal für die steckdose, einmal für den shelly, weil
der shelly braucht ja auch strom, dass er funktioniert und der shelly braucht einmal
das hier was letztendlich dann zur lampe geht, also quasi strom rein, strom raus zur lampe,
strom für den shelly, strom zurück und hier kommt der switch dann dran, das müsst ihr
eigentlich noch machen, genau und hier kommt an sv kommt der ausgang vom schalter, so wie
auch immer, das hab ich mittlerweile kapiert, wie man es richtig anschließt, zumindest
wenn diese konstellation so hier ist und das krieg ich auch gebacken, aber ich muss halt
die sicherung vorher raus machen, was ist der problem, also leute, also wenn ihr so planlos
seid wie ich, fuddelt erstens nicht daran rum, ohne irgendwie halbwegs verstanden zu
haben was wo wie dran muss und macht auf jeden fall die sicherung vorher raus, kommt nicht
auf die idee, selbst wenn ihr irgendwelche dicken gummihandschuhe habt, irgendwelche
elektriker, schraubendreher, sonst was, macht die sicherung raus, das sollte eigentlich
ganz logisch sein, aber ich sag's nur nochmal, killt euch nicht, ja, da brennt nix ab, zweifelsfall
fliegt die sicherung raus oder es gibt ja kurzschlussendens fliegt die sicherung raus,
kennst du dich mit der ha-proxy aus, nur ein bisschen, der braune ist glaube ich das kabel
zur lampe, das hier ist das kabel zur lampe, das ist strom rein und strom raus zur lampe,
wenn ich das richtig sehe hier, der shelly passt hinter den schalter, deswegen ist er
ja auch so komisch gebaut, bei einer schlechten verbindung zwischen klemme und kabel, siehste,
deswegen werde ich mir jetzt gleich ne runde klemme kaufen und ein kabel, so, also am ende
sieht das so aus, wenn du das wieder einbaust, also das kann natürlich nach jedem schalter
ein bisschen anders aussehen, wenn du das einbaust, dann musst du ein bisschen fuddeln
und dann sieht das ganze so aus, ja, richtig, so siehts aus, da kriegste nicht nur einfach
ein gewischt, da bist du im zweifelsfall press f im chat, wenns schlecht läuft, vor allem
wenn du so schön mit beiden händen noch dran greifst, dann ist komplett, da könne
ich dir respekt payen, so das ganze reinzukriegen ist ein bisschen fummelig, so, so gehts dann
wieder zu, exellent, also seht ihr, deswegen ist der shelly so gebaut, weil er unten drunter
passt, danach, ja das ist ja grad das gute, danach funktioniert der lichtschalter wie
vorher, nur dass der lichtschalter dann nicht mehr direkt das licht einen ausschaltet,
sondern der lichtschalter schaltet den shelly und der shelly schaltet das licht, also du
hast dann quasi das beste aus beiden welten, du kannst dein licht übers wlan an und ausschalten
und du kannst das licht über den normalen schalter an und ausschalten, und das geht
auch ziemlich schnell, also das ist nicht irgendwie zwei sekunden verzögerung oder sowas, ich
mein so ein relay, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was das durchschnitts relay
so für eine verzögerung hat, aber das dürfte im millisekundenbereich sein, ich mein die
sind wahrscheinlich mechanisch, mechanische relays, was haben die 100 millisekunden oder
so, das wirst du nicht großartig merken, dd1921, dafür ist genau diese dinger ganz gut, gut
das kann natürlich sein, du kannst den schalter aushaben und was, ne wenn du den schalter
aushast, ja doch, wenn du den schalter aushast und du hast im shelly das eingeschaltet,
der shelly drückt ja nicht dein schalter runter, ja das da stimmt, also sprich du schaltest
mit dem schalter, würde ich mal sagen immer, im zweifel musst du es zweimal drücken oder,
wie funktioniert das dann, wie funktioniert denn das, wie funktioniert denn das, wenn
ich nen schalter hab, der schalter schaltet den shelly, das heißt, also mal angenommen,
ich hab das jetzt alles angeschlossen und schalte mit dem schalter, der schalter ist
aus, so oder sagen wir so, der schalter ist an, ne der schalter ist aus, so der schalter
ist ausgeschaltet und ich schalte jetzt übers wlan das licht ein, dann ist der schalter
ja immer noch aus, das heißt, wenn ich dann den schalter einschalte, dann bleibt das licht
nicht an, sondern er schaltet das licht aus oder, also sprich jedes mal, wenn ich den
schalter betätige, egal was ist, er macht das andere, also sprich, wenn das licht an
ist und ich drücke den schalter gehts aus oder nicht, ne das kann nicht sein, der schalter,
ne ne ne, das kann nicht sein, der schalter schaltet ja nur, wenn er auf an ist, das toggelt
ja nicht hin und her, also sprich, wenn der schalter aus ist, ok, genau, wenn der schalter
aus ist und ich über das wlan mein licht einschalte und ich möchte das licht über
den schalter wieder ausschalten, dann muss ich den schalter vorher erst einschalten und
dann wieder ausschalten oder, ne, ok, ok, was ist wenns umgedreht ist, was ist wenns
umgedreht ist, ich hab den schalter auf an und mach das licht über den shelly aus, so
und ich möchte dann das licht über den schalter, geht das überhaupt, kann ich den schalter
auf an haben und den shelly den licht ausschalten, ja ja, das müsste funktionieren, aber das
wird doch dann auch bedeuten, wenn ich den schalter auf an hab und den shelly auf aus
stelle übers wlan, dann muss ich um das licht wieder anzumachen den schalter erst ausschalten
und wieder einschalten oder, ne, das was spiderl schreibt klingt doch viel logischer, ach
was auch immer, keine ahnung, ich werds demnächst wissen, so und zumindest es gibt noch die
shelly ls, die brauchen irgendwie keinen, ja genau, die brauchen kein nullleiter, funktioniert
auch so, was das wird gleich im video behandelt, äh dann soll ich das video vielleicht mal
aufmachen, moment, dann hören wir uns das video doch mal kurz an, ups, so, am ende
woran das handy da, das video geht noch 3 minuten, das können wir uns noch kurz angucken,
so nachdem reiner den shelly in die elektrik integriert hat, wollen wir uns jetzt um die
software kümmern, das heißt wir haben jetzt ein android handy, in dem wir die shelly cloud
app bereits installiert haben, ja übrigens ist es total, es ist total wir, die ist tatsächlich,
das ist total wir, dass das ding shelly cloud heißt, das ganze zeug, eine der großen vorteile
von den shellys ist, dass sie ohne cloud funktionieren, also richtig beknackt, dass es shelly cloud
heißt, kann man den shelly ins apple home einbinden, also wenn apple home, ich hab das
noch nie verwendet, standardsachen unterstützt wie mqtt oder http requests, dann geht das
nicht, und sollte es das nicht unterstützen, also sollte apple home keine mqtt messages
oder http messages schicken können, ist es schrott, weil das komplett weltweiter standard
ist, also mich würde echt wundern, wenn es nicht geht, ja das, ich mach das über mqtt,
man kann das so über dir machen, so max man kommt, ne du heißt gar nicht max oder, ich
glaube serious max heißt gar nicht max, es ist jubate, ach doch ok, den shelly hat er
schon gefunden, irgendeiner im chat hat mich mal übel jubate mit einem namen, der total
klingt wie ein real life namen, aber gar nicht sein name ist, so wann kommt das, ja das
kenne ich, ha jubated, you got jubated, so wann kommt das denn mit den schaltern, also
wenn er vielleicht im büro ist, max was sagt er das denn, jetzt haben wir es hier stehen
im badezimmer, ich kann es ein und ausschalten, ja, sieht sehr schick aus, das zeichen oben
links in der ecke mit den zwei pfeilen bedeutet, dass die firmware auf dem shelly aktualisiert
werden kann, ich hab, mein shelly ist zwei jahre alt oder so, ich hab mich einmal firmware
aktualisiert, jetzt können wir uns, können wir dann auch gleich mal mit durchziehen,
genau ok, machen wir, kann das gerät auch mal aktualisiert werden, ja das war es soweit
zur grundanrichtung, wir werden uns, äh, also didi, wenn das was ist, was du an die,
da würde ich was anderes nehmen, also wenn das was ist, was du in die steckdose steckst,
da würde ich irgendeine wlan steckdose nehmen, nicht unbedingt so ein unterputz shelly ding,
es sei denn du willst halt, dass man es nicht sieht, dann, dann geht das bestimmt auch irgendwie,
aber, dann würde ich irgendeine andere wlan steckdose nehmen, aber jetzt haben wir erstmal
den shelly für die app fertig gemacht, das heißt rana kann jetzt auch, wenn mal irgendjemand
wieder das badezimmerlicht ausmacht, im badezimmer über sein handy, das licht anschalten, ja
ok, so was kommt, ach hier, hier er zeigt das jetzt, ok, der shelly ist ein reines wlan
gerät, wenn es hier verbaut ist und martin den shelly in der app eingerichtet hat, werden
wir euch natürlich zeigen wie es funktioniert, als erstes ganz klassisch, tue auf, dunkel,
tue auf erstmal geschissen, licht an, licht aus, zusätzlich kommt jetzt noch dazu die
app, seht ihr den ring sofort an, licht an, licht ist an, licht aus, licht ist aus, jetzt
ist halt die frage, betätige ich mal, ok schalter an, und ihr seht der ring ist da,
jetzt kann ich allerdings, so und was passiert wenn ihr jetzt den schalter drückt, geht
jetzt das licht einfach wieder an, also egal wie ich schalte, es geht immer hin und her,
ok, sehr gut, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen das video, also der schalter macht immer das
gegenteil von dem was ist, also der schalter ist quasi so ne typische not oder nicht, schaltung
quasi, also der schalter macht immer das was nicht gerade ist, invertor, genau ein invertor
genau da, das ist exzellent chat, hier heute ist wieder absolut massive brain angesagt
hier, wisst ihr was ich auch hier richtig geil finde so im chat, ich mein es ist in
jedem, überall auf twitter, twitch, sonst wo, gibt es ganz viele leute die so tun als
hätten sie von allem plan, allerdings gibt es hier im chat leute die wirklich ahnung
haben von dem was sie machen, oder was sie sagen, das ist beim internet gar nicht gewöhnt,
eigentlich bin ich im internet gewöhnt, dass jeder zu jedem thema was sagt, obwohl er keine
ahnung hat, und hier sagt jeder zu jedem thema was, und es haben sogar leute ahnung, wahnsinn,
true he doesn't know, he lacks critical information, so genau, also ich hab mir hiervon noch 5
stück vorbestellt, und die will ich jetzt endlich mal einbauen, deswegen brauch ich
folgendes, ich hab zwar ein paar kisten, das sind keine kisten, das sind eher becher,
becher sind das, von diesen klemmen, aber ich hab nur die klemmen einmal für 2 und
einmal für 3, das reicht dafür nicht, also ich hab quasi nur davon welche und davon
welche, so, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, für meine shelly einbau aktion, bestelle
ich mir einfach noch ne runde davon oder so, so welche, was ist denn der unterschied zwischen
sowas, ok das ist nur zum stecken, das ist nur zum stecken, und das hier ist zum stecken
und klipsen, 5, warum gibt es, was ist die existenzberechtigung, was ist die existenzberechtigung
davon und davon, also warum gibt es beides, und warum gibt es die hier dann auch noch,
ok das hier geht für dicken kabel nicht gut, also das hier ist, hiervon hab ich welche,
ich hab hiervon die mit 2 und 3 und glaub ich sogar 4, ne 2 und 3, ich hab 2 verschiedene,
aber die hier ist für weiche, weichere kabel, damit funktioniert das wunderbar, damit hab
ich ja auch hier die verkabelung in hier gemacht, nein, nein, jetzt geht das wieder los, not
like this, hier, da ist er, also mit so weichen sachen hab ich das ja hier mit gemacht, passt
ja auch aber für dickere kabel geht das glaube ich nicht, die grauen sind für andere kabel
und ein gen, was ist denn ein gen, ein weg, also quasi einmal zu und dann nie wieder auf
oder was ist bei dir ein gen, so also für meine shelly verkabelungs sachen, ach erste
generation, ok, was soll ich, was ist für meine shelly verkabelungs aktion besser, die
mit klippen, die zum klippen oder die zum stecken, also der dude hier im video hat ja
die gelben oder, hallo wo ist der video, wo ist der video dude, ja der hat ja die gelben,
aber was ist denn der unterschied, was ist denn der unterschied, also hier ist ne reine
steckverbindung, hier ist ne reine steckverbindung, also man steckt die rein und hier sind dann
irgendwelche wiederhaken oder so drinne, dass die halt schön feststecken, so und hier kann
man die quasi fest klipps, ach nee, moment, die hier sind für kabel, die aus unterschied,
also die aus kleinen kabels bestehen, aha, weil ich hab ja was durchgängiges dann, oder
ist das egal, na weil die hier, hier sieht man ja, hier sind die kabel auch durchgängig
fest, ah da nehme ich ne packung von den gelben, so und jetzt ist die nächste sache, jetzt
ist die nächste sache, was brauche ich denn für kabel, ich hab glaub ich nämlich für
diese ganze shelly aktion nicht genug kabels, also ich brauche, wie nennt man das, ich hab
mal vor ner weile geguckt und ich glaube diese sorte von kabel heißt irgendwie so ne, kann
man das, sowas hier glaub ich, aber natürlich nicht so teuer, genau sowas, sowas hier im
endeffekt, ok ich nehm 10m, weil 5m kosten nur 40 cent weniger, ich weiß das, brauchst
du 5 adrich, nee, aber ich nehm eh die adern da raus, gibts die sachen einzeln, gibts das
einzeln ohne kabel, also was ich hier dran ganz cool finde ist, aber was hier dran ganz
cool ist, dass unterschiedliche farben sind, also sprich, gibts hier also, nach was suche
ich denn da hier, nach da, da, draht oder so, was ich soll, nee litzen sind ja nicht
die durchgängigen, das sind ja die, die, die, mit, ah nee, nur, nur draht, draht, sowas
hier, das ist aber teurer als, das ist aber teurer als das ganze kabel mit, mit, mit
alle möglichen drinnen, was H05, draht, mach einfach nur was der chat sagt, aha, sowas
hier, ach sowas hier, sowas hier oder, chat sowas, nee, das sind aber zu klein, guck mal,
das sind, was, jetzt mal blöde Frage, was spricht denn dagegen, wenn ich, wenn ich
das nehme, was ich hier eben hatte, äh, wenn ich das nehme und einfach die kabel da raus
ziehe, ich mein, ich kann, aus den kabeln kann man total easy die kabel rausziehen,
viel unnötig Geld und Arbeit, ok, die leitungen sind da nicht so flexibel, das macht nix,
da mach ich das doch so, da nehm ich, weil, ich mein, scheiß drauf, hier krieg ich 10
Meter für 11 Euro und hab 5 verschiedene farben und kabels drinnen, passt doch wunderbar,
ist doch alles in Ordnung, kann man doch, kann man doch machen, also ich weiß halt nicht
mehr nach was ich suchen muss, dass ich die einzeln finde, ach komm mal hier, sowas hier,
ah ja, ordentlich verkehrt, äh, allerdings brauche ich das ganze in, äh, mit, von, von,
wo man das über prime kriegt, boah, ist das kryptische bezeichnung, alter, meine fresse,
ah, hier so, jetzt machen wir hier amazon prime, hier sowas, ha, brauchst du wirklich
10 Meter, nee nicht wirklich, aber das ist das kleinste was es gibt, das ist viel zu
viel, da, da, da kann ich ja, das halbe haus neu verkabeln mit, ich hab immer noch keine
Ahnung was ich kaufen soll, alter, ah, Moment, hier hat, hier hat einer was verlinkt im chat,
nee, das ist ja, das ist ja schon auch eingepackt, das ist, äh, was willst du eigentlich machen
beziehungsweise, ich will meine shellies verbauen, ich will sowas hier machen, äh, will sowas
hier machen, sowas will ich hier machen, sowas will ich machen, deswegen will, ich will,
sowas so mit durchgängigen kabeln, also keine, keine einzelnen kleinen trete drin, jetzt
dreht der cheddarbrat, ja, was ist denn der unterschied zwischen h07v und nim, what the
fuck, oder ist es das gleiche, nimm ist das wenn außen drum herum was ist oder wie, wisst
ihr was, ich nehm jetzt einfach diese rolle, bis mir jetzt, wow, ich nehm jetzt einfach
diese rolle hier und gut ist, so, chat, fertig aus, dann ich zieh das hier aus dem, ich zieh
das hier raus und gut ist, die, die gehen auf jeden fall, und 11 Euro werde ich noch verkraften,
so, exzellent, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so schlecht wenn die in nem kabel sind, ah,
das y ist isolierung und außen rum, aha, ah, kingwall, echt, der chat ist wirklich big
brain, guck mal, jetzt lernt man sogar noch was, normleitung, ok, isolierung, das ist das
was außen rum ist, meint die damit das graue um das kabel oder meinen die das schwarze
plastik um die kabel, schwarze, rote, gelbe plastik um die kabel oder meinen die außen
rum das graue, so, y ist mit grün gelbem schutz leider, aha, das ist ja wirklich big brain
chat wieder exquisite, exzellent, exzellent, tja, hier lernt man was, mindblown, ist echt
so, in diesem chat ist mehr IQ als heute in ganz berlin, wieso ist in berlin wieder
antikoronademo oder was ist da, die sind so bescheuert, eh, also nicht damit einverstanden
sein ist das eine, brandsätze werfen ist das andere, aber man muss jetzt auch hier wieder
dazu sagen, man kann die jetzt schlecht über einen kamm scheren, ich find's auch immer
nicht gut wenn da stehen irgendwie 1000 koronaleugner, ich wette mit euch, das sind keine 2.000,
1.000 koronaleugner, sondern das sind vielleicht prinzipiell mal 2.000 leute, die mit irgendwas
nicht einverstanden sind, ich glaube die ganz, ganz, wirklich ganz winzig kleine zahl der
leute, die da wirklich hingehen und demonstrieren sind wirklich koronaleugner, die sind dann
so in richtung, hier xavier neidu, es gibt keine viren und sowas, ja, der ganz, ganz,
weil um wirklich korona zu, dass du sagst, viren gibt es nicht, korona gibt es nicht,
da musst du schon wirklich ziemlich, ziemlich durch seinem kopf, dass du kritik an den koronamaßnahmen
hast, dazu musst du einfach nur ein bisschen nachdenken, weil da läuft vieles nicht so
wie es laufen sollte, aber es ist ja auch ein unterschied ob man sagt, hey ich hab
was gegen die koronamaßnahmen, wie das läuft oder ich bestreite, dass es viren gibt, das
eine ist einfach nur, eh, erkenntnisse der letzten 100 oder was weiß ich, eh, oder 80
jahre irgendwie, oder weiß ich nicht, wann viren entdeckt wurden, ignoriert und das andere
ist zumindest, ist normal nachgedacht, so, eh, zumindest ich werde jetzt das hier mal
bestellen, das ist eine gute kombination, ich hab jetzt hier die klemmen, also die klemmen
muss ich noch bestellen, ich bestell mir jetzt hier mal die klemmen und hab mir das kabel
bestellt, sehr schön, warum sind das 5, achso, 3 stück davon und 2 mal davon, ok, ich muss
nix neu vertraten, ne die wagos mit hebel waren glaub ich nicht so sinnvoll, weil die
haben sich ja quasi reingebissen irgendwie so in die kabel und das geht ja nicht, wenn
die kabel durchgängig sind, so richtig gut oder, ich hab übrigens einmal den fehler
gemacht und habe, ehm, netzwerkstecker gekrimmt auf, wie nennt man das eigentlich, dass ich
das jetzt richtig sag, es gibt ja einmal kabel, die sind massiv, kupfer innen drinnen, durchgängig
und es gibt, ehm, und es gibt kabel, die bestehen aus ganz vielen kleinen einzelnen kabel, also
sprich, es gibt kabel, die bestehen aus ganz vielen kleinen treten und es gibt kabel, die
ist durchgängig kupfer, starr und flexibel, ah ok, also ich hab mal nen netzwerkstecker
gekrimmt auf starre kabel, die dafür nicht gedacht sind, das geht, wenn man fest genug
drückt mit der krimmzange, aber stabil und lange haltbar ist es nicht, das hab ich gemacht,
weil mir nix anderes übrig blieb, weil ich POE machen wollte, vom ersten stock ins erdgeschoss
und ich hatte dort nur so diese normalen klingeldrahtdinger mit durchgehendem kabel
drinne und da hab ich halt einfach mal probiert, man musste wirklich feste feste mit der krimmzange
drücken, das hat funktioniert, aber es ging dann auch relativ schnell wieder kaputt, also
gut war das nicht geklappt, so dieser draht hier zum beispiel, der da drin ist, das ist
so durchgängiges zeug, aber wenn du jetzt, der chat schreibt doch gerade, ey jetzt sind
es nur noch 4 auf einmal, die dinger sind nur gut für starre kabeln, das sind doch starre
kabel, also passt doch alles wunderbar zusammen, starre kabel für starre klemmen, ja stimmt,
wenn ich doch mal was flexibles verbinden will, aber ich hab ja noch 2 dosen mit den
alten und 5er brauche ich selten, also ich hab ja noch 2er und 3er, ne alte ist jetzt
auch wurscht, ich kann ja seit ewig damit rum machen, aber was ich da nicht verstehe,
hier zeigen sie ja auf dem bild, dass man keine starren kabel nimmt, sondern so flexible,
kann man die auch für starre kabeln verwenden, weil hier auf dem bild nicht, ach das geht
auch, ok, ich hoffe doch nicht du willst die sprechanlage mit dem kabel da machen, was,
eh das ist was, was ich schon lange gemacht hab, hier hab ich den esp32 angeschlossen,
hier oben sieht man übrigens noch den stecker, den aj45 stecker, den ich auf so starre dinger
mal drauf gekrimmt hab und das so nicht gut funktioniert hat, hier hab ich den esp32 reingebaut
und er erkennt, wanns klingelt, wenn ich nen fachmann hole, warte ich nen halbes jahr und
bezahle was weiß ich, wieviel bis denn der mir meine 10 cellys eingebaut hat, das kann
ich schon selbst machen, ich hab doch den chat, der chat erzählt mir doch nie was blödes,
kann der chat nie machen, so ich bin jetzt, also ich lasse das jetzt so, ich kauf mir
die kabels und ich kauf mir die klemmen und dann wird eingebaut, gutes, von der vago seite
installation von ein fein und mehr tretiger leiter, aha, hast du cellys, ja ich hab ganz
viele cellys und erst ein celly im einsatz, was hast du für ne sprechanlage, ja ich hab
nen video, aber das ist nicht über die sprechanlage gelöst, also an gegensprechanlage hab ich
so ein olles ding, weil es halt damals noch schon dran war halt, wenn du so willst, ich
bin nicht rausgesucht, da ist nix smart dran, das schöne daran ist, es ist robust und funktioniert
und video mach ich folgendermaßen, ich hab, wie man ja hier sieht, auf dem bild, ach nee,
also hier daneben hängt nen tablet, rechts daneben, so und ich hab ne kamera und ich hab
nen esp32 eingebaut, hier, da ist nen esp32 drin, also hier dahinter und wenn der controller
erkennt, dass es klingelt, dann geht die kamera auf dem tablet an, ist eigentlich ne ganz
gute kombination, da muss ich nix großartig umbauen an der gegensprechanlage und ich seh
trotzdem wer vor der tür steht und kann mit dem reden, welche cellys ich habe, die hier
will ich einbauen, also ich hab mir da vor ner ganzen weile schonmal nen großen schwung
von gekauft und ich wollte jetzt mal endlich den kram einbauen, wie bekommt der espstrom
über usb, das funktioniert folgendermaßen, man erkennt es hier nicht, nicht richtig gut
auf dem bild, hier oben hängt nen, ich überleg grad von was auf was das ist, 12 volt auf
usb, genau, so, genau, also, der esp bekommt strom über, also es hängt unten nen netzteil
dran, ich hab noch ein paar freie kabel gehabt von dieser installation von der gegensprechanlage
und da hab ich unten nen netzteil, nen 12 volt netzteil angeschlossen und greif das
hier drüber ab, also nicht da drüber, sondern, oder vielleicht, ich weiß nicht wie alt das
bild ist ehrlich gesagt, zumindest hab ich hier nen 12 volt auf usb adapter drinnen
und daran hängt der esp32, der 12 volt auf usb hängt hier oben, der ist da oben in die
ecke gepappt, ja so funktioniert das aktuell, so der esp32 erkennt wenns klingelt, wenns
klingelt krieg ich ne nachricht aufs handy geschickt und ich bekomme auf dem tablet hier
nebendran die kamera von der eingangstür angezeigt, exellent, genau, also ich hab mir
das auch schon überlegt, weil es eben grad im chat thema war, ob ich mir nicht wirklich
mal jemand hole, der mir das alles einbaut, aber ganz ehrlich, das letzte mal haben die
nen riesen ag gemacht, das hat irgendwie 6 wochen oder so gedauert bis einer vorbeigekommen
ist, meine 2 neuen steckdosen im keller hab ich heute noch nicht, das hab ich vor nem
halben jahr dem kell schonmal erzählt und er ist nicht angerückt und außerdem, ich
hab da zwar keine ahnung von der, also ich bin kein elektriker, das heißt bei der theorie
her haberts bei mir, aber wenn ichs mir im vorfeld angeguckt hab, wie man den kram anschließen
muss, dann trau ich mir das zu, das anzuschließen, ich mein ich hab schon andere sachen hingewurstet,
hingewurstet ist vielleicht das falsche wort, aber die deutlich komplizierter waren als
da 5 kabel in die richtigen sachen zu stecken und da muss schon wirklich ganz, ganz schlimm
was verkackt werden, wie soll da was abfackeln, seit wann hast du das haus und was hast du
noch so smart, das kann ich jetzt nicht alles erzählen, das haus also eingezogen sind wir
2013, das ist geerbt vom opa, 2013 sind wir eingezogen und so richtig angefangen mit
heimautomatisierung hab ich erst so vor ungefähr 3 jahren, wie findest du die shellys und deren
app, ich hab damit so gut wie nix, ich hab hier zwar einen schon testweise mal angeschlossen
ja, aber ich hab nicht wirklich was mit der offiziellen shelly app gemacht, mach das alles
über mqtt und verwende die app gar nicht, du musst noch nicht mal die app installieren,
um den shelly in betrieb zu nehmen, wenn ich das noch richtig in erinnerung hab, du kannst
das auch über das webinterface komplett machen, also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, man konnte
den shelly anschließend sich verbinden zu einem hotspot, wlan einrichten und dann das
über das webinterface oder mqtt machen, ohne dass man die app überhaupt gebraucht hat und
ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, das ist bei den neuen shellys immer noch so und cloud
und account braucht man auch nicht, deswegen ist es ziemlich blöd, dass die dinger shelly.cloud
heißen.
und achja, die dinger sind wirklich cool, ich hab letztens sogar ein video mal gesehen
bei einem der smart home leute, die ich mir auf youtube so angucke, diese unify tür gegensprechanlagen,
was mir da dran halt nicht gefällt ist, dass man die telephonen, die im flur hängen nicht
überverwenden kann und was mir da auch nicht gefällt ist, dass es im zweifelsfall nicht
funktioniert, wenn wlan ausfällt, wobei die sind glaub ich per kabel oder?
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, sind die mit kabel?
zumindest du brauchst halt hardware auf der gegenseite und wenn die ausfällt geht die
klingel nicht, das ist an diesem ollen siedler ding ganz gut, weil das geht immer, das funktioniert
immer, egal was ist, nur stromausfall kann dafür sorgen, dass es nicht mehr funktioniert.
aber ich muss jetzt erst ein paar andere sachen ordern bei amazon oder bei amazon, wie das
die coolen leute sagen.
also ich hab jetzt die kabel zeug hab ich schon, so dann möchte ich mir noch mal eine
rgb lampe kaufen und zwar, ich hab mir die hier bestellt, 60, 60 oder so, die ist nice,
übrigens viel zu teuer, müssen wir mal gucken, dass ihr die ein bisschen günstiger bekommt.
ich hab mir die hier bestellt, die ist wirklich cool, weil die ist im vergleich zu den meisten
anderen smart cuppa pride lampen ziemlich hell, die hat glaub ich 2000, ne 1000 lumen
2000 lumen irgendwie im moment, 1100 lumen, ne ne ne guck mal, ich würd die nicht kaufen
für 40 euro, ich würd gucken, dass ich die irgendwo günstiger kriege, das ist schon
ganz schön teuer, aber die ist ziemlich hell und ich find die lampe wirklich cool, die
sache ist nur die, die ist dadurch durch diese form, ist die ein bisschen, also die
geht nicht nach hinten, das ist ja so, also so normale klübirne, da geht das licht ja
in alle richtungen, oder was so eine normale lampe, da geht das licht ja mehr oder weniger
in alle richtungen, bei denen hier geht das licht zum größten teil so kegelförmig nach
vorne, die sind denk ich ganz gut, wenn man damit zum beispiel so ne deckenflute hat oder
wenn man indirekt irgendwelche sachen beleuchten will, aber ich glaube so als deckenlampe sind
die nicht so geil, ja die yeelight dinger die wollt ich auch mal ausprobieren, die dinger
wollt ich auch mal ausprobieren, äh deswegen hab ich überlegt, nachdem ich an sich das
hier, wie gesagt ich hab mir da eine bestellt, an sich, hallo, wo war ich denn eben hier,
ganz cool fand, die haben wir auch noch kleinere mini irgendwas, die haben wir auch noch so
welche, die übrigens auch hier bei amazon viel viel viel zu teuer sind, da wollt ich
davon mal eine ausprobieren, weil die leuchten ein bisschen ein bisschen runter, wie hell
sind die hier, 800 ok, so und warum ich mir das jetzt hole ist, weil eben im chat die
frage kam, ne ne nicht mit china app, die kannst du in home assistant einbinden ohne
dass du die china app brauchst, wäre ja auch noch schöner, ich benutze doch keine, also
ihr kennt mich leute, ich flasche schreckdosen aus china, nur dass keine china firmware mehr
drauf ist, glaubt ihr doch nicht, dass ich lampen verwende mit china firmware und china
app, im leben nicht, äh du hast doch bei dir tablets an der wand hängen, wie mountest
du die, ich würd's dir ja gerne zeigen, wenn ich das bild dazu finden würde, ich guck
mal, ich zeig dir das bild zu, dann kann man das nämlich besser sehen, ich hab da ein bild
von, ja und mit den lampen ist so, wenn man die shellys hat zum ein und ausschalten braucht
man die nicht, aber möchte man ein bisschen unterschiedliche farben haben, das ist das,
wo ich gerade ein bisschen am experimentieren bin, weil ich jetzt so viele beleuchtungsvideos
geguckt hab auf youtube, da bringt dir der shelly natürlich nix, wichtig ist nur, dass
man die lampen so einstellen kann, dass sie sich die settings merken, also sprich, wenn
du ein und ausschaltest, dass sie sich nicht auf einmal resetten oder so komische dinger,
so ich guck mal kurz ob ich's finde, aimtraining hier, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, ah da ist es,
da ist das tablet an der wand, also, man siehts hier vielleicht schon, gar nicht gemountet,
das ist dazwischen geklemmt, zwischen, ähm, tür, gegensprechanlage und wand, aber das
coole ist, das hält richtig fest, das sind fire hd10 ja, das hält richtig fest, also
man hätte im, also das war in dem haus schon so eingebaut, diese gegensprechanlage, ne,
und ich hätte sie nicht besser einbauen können, ich hätte das ding nicht besser einbauen
können von der entfernung her, ja chat wo ist das problem, also guck mal, achso, übrigens
das kabel hab ich mittlerweile ein kürzeres genommen und hier ein bisschen reingesteckt,
aber trotzdem, achja, also es ist mittlerweile tatsächlich ein bisschen anders, der 12 volt
dieser stecker ist weg, ich glaub den hab ich ganz abgemacht, der ist nicht im gehäuse,
der ist ganz weg, brauch ich hier eh nicht, und das kabel ist ähm, andersrum, genau, ich
hab's jetzt rumgedreht, ich hab's rumgedreht, das stromstecker ist jetzt unten und geht
hier neben rein, dort wo das kabel hier raus geht, geht der stromstecker quasi mehr oder
weniger rein, und ähm, dadurch dass das usb kabel hier neben steckt, theoretisch brauchst
die hier neben gar nicht mehr dieses schaumstoffding, dass es hält, es hält richtig gut, wie gesagt
ich wohne gegenüber vom bahnhof, hier rumpelt's ab und zu mal ein bisschen mit güterzug,
da wackelt nix, da passiert nix, und dadurch dass ich jetzt umgedreht hab und das usb kabel
untenrum gemacht hab, siehts auch besser aus, das ist wie die wandhalterung von wish, genau,
ein abgewinkeltes kabel ist gar keine schlechte idee, man müsste sich halt ein nach links
abgewinkeltes kabel kaufen, das ist glaube, gibt's sowas, gibt es ein nach links abgewinkeltes
usb kabel, äh, ich hab da drauf einmal mein home assistant, also wie gesagt ich kann dir
jetzt halt nur die demo davon zeigen, weil ich sonst Sachen leake, also ungefähr sieht
das bei mir, also nein, ehrlich gesagt siehts bei mir ganz anders aus, aber die oberfläche
sieht so ähnlich aus, auch hier mit nem thermostat und sowas, das hab ich da drauf
laufen im browser, und äh, die cameras, zwei sachen, allerdings ist normalerweise die heimautomatisierungsapp
auf, und wenn der esp32 erkennt, dass es klingelt, dann entlockt er das bildschirm,
also dann macht er den bildschirm an und macht die camera app auf, also es passiert automatisch,
also sprich nach ungefähr, sagen wir mal zwei sekunden oder so, ist das camera bild
dann hier komplett geladen drauf, zwei sekunden sind schnell genug, wenn ich aufstehe und
zum tablet, zum hörer laufe, brauch ich länger als zwei sekunden, ja, so siehts aus, so,
aber die sind mir zu teuer, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, ob es die irgendwie anders günstiger
gibt, ne, die sind alle, warum ist der kram alles so teuer, oh, das wäre eigentlich zu
teuer, stopp dann, das, wahrscheinlich kauf ich mir dann doch nicht, ich sehs nicht, 41
euro für lampe zu bezahlen, beste usb-kabel, zeig mal her, ja, what the f, nice, top usb-kabel,
audioquest diamond, was ein schwachsinn, aber es kaufen wahrscheinlich noch leute, nur noch
10 stück in stock, oh mein gott, nein, wie viel shipping, ach easy, ne, das ist nicht
348 shipping, das gibt es auch, mit für 348 und free shipping, guck mal, was ein schnäppchen,
welch ein schnäppchen, ganz toll, aber benutzt, ja, ganz tragisch, ja, also gibt es, hey,
es gibt echt schräg abgewinkelte usb-kabel, chat, sehr gute idee, ich weiß nicht, wer
es hatte, das gefällt mir richtig gut, oh, das ist nice, guck mal, wenn ich hier, also
das usb-kabel ist unten, das heißt, so, das heißt, ich kauf mir ein abgewinkeltes usb-kabel,
aber moment, geht das denn dann auch in die richtige richtung, ja, müsste, ne, was, schau
mal nach einem 180 grad kabel, also so einfach lasse ich mich nicht debaten, was soll denn
ein 180 grad kabel sein, also normalerweise ist der stecker hier, 180 grad bedeutet, das
ist einfach umgedreht, was, 100, 100, moment, ernsthaft, kabel, was soll denn das sein,
what the fuck, das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert nicht, Leute, guck mal, dahinter
ist ja kein platz, das ist ja direkt an der wand, das funktioniert nicht, was der anderseite,
vielleicht doch, ich mein, guck doch mal, ne, das funktioniert nicht, also das tablet,
das tablet dürfte ungefähr so dick hier sein, das tabletgehäuse dürfte bis hier hingehen
und ich glaube nicht, dass ich hinter dem tablet genug platz habe, das langzuführen, zumal
ich ja auch dann hier wieder rein muss, wobei das, wisst ihr was, mal ganz ehrlich, leute,
man kann sowas immer gebrauchen, ich glaube, ich bestell mir einfach mal eins, was gibt
es denn da für unterschiedliche varianten, das da, was sieht denn besser aus, eigentlich
vollkommen egal, das da ist ganz schön lang, wow, ach du scheiße, was ist das, what the
fuck, usb vga und klinke auf hdmi, monkaS, ok, es gibt anscheinend nur diese zwei dinger,
so und was ist davon, man kann jetzt die Größe hier schlecht einschätzen, aber, ach, moment,
das ist usb c, oder, ach ne, ich brauch gar nicht, ich brauch micro usb, da bleibt ja
nur das, moment, das ist auch usb c, ach ne, ne, ne, ich brauch micro usb, micro usb brauche
ich, iii, uuuh, oh das, das haben wir heute morgen gelernt, leute, das ist ein micro,
ein usb, micro, ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt, ein usb, micro b, ne, ein usb, usb,
micro b, micro 3b, aber usb, ja wisst ihr was, anscheinend gibt es das gar nicht, anscheinend
gibt es gar kein 180 grad micro usb kabel, das ist alles usb c, ach ich krieg grad was
im chat geschickt, zeig mal her, ne, ne, das ist, das ist der winkel zur seite, so welche
hatte ich ja schon, so welche, so welche hatten wir ja schon, aber die sind richtig schön
dünn, kann das sein, ja ich glaub ich nehm, jaja ich glaub ich nehm wirklich so ein winkel
zur seite, micro usb 90 grad, sowas hier, also ich nehm schon mal keins mit grüner lampe
dran, weil das nervt mich, dann leuchtet es dann nachts am tablet, ich nehm mir ja eben
sowas billiges hier, irgendwie sowas da, wunderbar, das kabel ist zu dick, da muss ich ein loch
hier neben rein machen, die idee muss noch ein bisschen reifen bis ich da was gescheites
hinkrieg, naja left and right angled, also ich, ja schwierig zu sagen jetzt, anhand des
kabels, da muss ich jetzt mal reingucken wo hinten und wo vorne ist, also wie in welche
richtung der stecker geht, da muss ich mir noch mal gedanken drüber machen, da bestelle
ich jetzt nix, das muss ich mir erstmal angucken wie man das am besten macht, aber chat ich
verstehe gar nicht warum sich der chat so lustig macht hier, über meine geile tablet
installation, kann ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen, ich find die ganz toll meine tablet installation,
guck mal vor allem, vor allem die schleifspuren am tablet sind geil, wobei das sind keine
schleifspuren, ich glaub der rahmen hat ne lücke mittlerweile, weiß gar nicht was der
chat gegen meine tablet installation hat, richtige hacker installation, ein so formschön,
funktionell muss es sein ja, so nächste geschichte, also das haben wir jetzt schon, zack, dann
was brauche ich ansonsten noch, shellies hab ich offstream bestellt, also davon hab ich
noch fünf stück bestellt, man weiß ja nie, ähm, druck dir ein case für das tablet aus
und versteckst oder, nee, wenn ich den case ausdrucke, da passt das ja gar nicht mal so
schön hier nebendran, warum, juckt das nicht wenn da ein bisschen kabel rausguckt,
äh, die schlieren an der wand, da ist nichts was man streichen muss, da hab ich glaub ich
paar minuten bevor ich die, das foto gemacht hab, irgendein fisch auf der wand plattgehauen,
das ist bestimmt schon wieder weg, so was brauchen wir ansonsten noch, wie siehts eigentlich
gerade mit zigbee thermostaten aus, gibts da irgendwas zurzeit günstig, wie es gibt
da, äh, was, ich glaub google shopping ist kaputt, oh google shopping ist kaputt, sehr
gut, was es gibt shelly thermostate, ernsthaft, haben die sowas, shelly h und t, skill killer,
ja das hier, die hier beste, original studio code live server, oh, ah, dann temperatur
sensor, excellent, ähm, moment, was das, ne, ne, ich meine, ich meine so ein ding für
die heizung, ein heizungsthermostate, was die heizung direkt regeln kann, also sowas
hier, sowas hier quasi, so, übrigens, das ist auch das, was ich mir gekauft hab, allerdings
viel zu teuer bei amazon, maximal 30€, also maximal, ich hoffe ja immer noch, dass dieser
komische händler bei aliexpress es mal auf die reihe bekommt und nicht so ne hohe versandkosten
hat, ich meine, das kann doch nicht sein, ernst sein, dass der 41€ versandkosten haben
will, äh, mein, btf, ih, das, das sieht ja zum fürchten aus, also nachdem ich jetzt
schon ein thermostat, also eins dieser thermostate im einsatz hab, ähm, ich würd mir ja gerne
auch davon noch, noch, noch 5 stück kaufen oder so, allerdings, ja, äh, allerdings nicht
für den preis hier, das ist mir, das ist mir alles viel zu, viel zu teuer, letztens
hab ichs irgendwie hier gesehen bei, bei, irgendwie bei pearl oder so, aber das ist
so nen, das ist so nen laden, da bestell ich aus prinzip nix, das ist so nen, ich hab irgendwie
die übelste, die übelste abneigung gegen diesen laden, ich, das sieht aus, ich weiß,
dass es ein legit shop ist, ja, aber dieser laden, der sieht, der hat so nen dermaßen
hässliche webseite und so, das, das erinnert mich an so nen alten katalog zum bestellen
dieses ding, ich hab da übelst, ich will da nix bestellen, obwohl das eigentlich ganz
ok ist mit, äh, irgendwie 30 euro oder so pro thermostat, das ist in ordnung, das kann
man sich sogar geben, ja, was kosten denn 5, ok, 188 durch 5, 7, haha, lull, achso da
ist der hub dabei, ja, das braucht ja kein mensch, dieser hub, ist das hier, ich brauch
doch keinen extra hub dafür, das ist doch komplett unsinnig, wo man auch wieder sieht,
das ist alles china resale, letztendlich stehen da verschiedene hersteller drauf, es ist aber
alles das gleiche thermostat, vielleicht kauf ich mir doch noch nen 3er pack, aber ich will
bei diesem kack shop nix bestellen, das sieht so, so letztes Jahr tausend aus, dieser shop,
dass ich mir das nicht, nicht antun will, ich spekuliere noch drauf, dass dieser eine
china hersteller, ha, guck mal bei real kostet das gleiche einfach mal 60 euro, btf, warum
kostet das 60 euro, das kriegste bei aliexpress für 20 dollar, alt mit so viel versand, bei
ebay, ok bei ebay hab ich tatsächlich noch nicht gekostet, nee die sind auch eklig, die
gefallen mir auch nicht, also ich find dieses, deswegen hab ichs ja auch mal ausprobiert,
ich find das hier sowohl von optik her als auch der bedienung her ganz ok, deswegen hab
ich mir das auch zum ausprobieren mal bestellt, und jetzt nachdem ich das schon 1-2 wochen
im einsatz hab, muss ich sagen, ich finds gut, das gefällt mir ganz gut, das sieht optisch
schick aus und das ist auch eins zum drehen, ich mag ja thermostat, die man dreht, nicht
so mit knopf links rechts, aber bei ebay will ich auch nix bestellen, 35 euro kurz
bei ebay, vielleicht bestell ich mir dann doch bei pearl das 3er pack, aber pearl ich
will bei pearl nix bestellen, bei konrad hab ich ja nicht geschaut, nee, ich weiß gar
nicht ob die sowas haben, ah das sind andere, aber auch mega teuer, was ist denn das hier
los, warum soll ich den thermostat kaufen für 135 euro, ein wtf, wie macht man so sachen
wenn man nur eine bodenheizung hat, ich mein du könntest deine bodenheizung, je nachdem
wie du die steuerst, wenns ne fernbedienung ist, könntest du die fernbedienung quasi
anlernen an irgendeinem, also wenn du nix selbst programmieren willst, an so einem
teil, die kann man auch mit custom software verwenden, dem kannst du infra rot befehle
beibringen und wenn du ne fernbedienung für deine fußbodenheizung hast, sind die chancen
dass das infra rot fernbedienung ist, relativ hoch, und da könntest du die befehle dafür
dem ding beibringen und dann über deine heimautomatisierung steuern, das ding selbst kommt ins wlan und
das kann dann, musst du halt in den raum stellen mit sichtkontakt zum empfänger, ansonsten
fällt mir da nix ein, ja das könnt ich bei aliexpress machen, aber also angenomm ich,
wow, alter, btf, was ist mit dem versand kostenlos, sind die total irgendwie zurück geblieben
oder was, ich mein wenn ich 10 stück kaufe hab ich 100€ versandkosten, verkäufer konnte
nicht schiffartikel, ok moment, ja das ist bei aliexpress lohnt sich halt mal gar nicht
ne, sowas kauft man nicht alle 3 jahre neu, ich hoffe nicht, aber ich weiß nicht wie die
qualität dieser china dinger ist, ja genau chillfreak du hast den laden angeschrieben,
die meinen bei 5 stück 35-45 versandkosten, naja ok, gehen wir mal davon aus, das würde
mir dann bedeuten, was 21,69 was, 69 cent mal 5 ok, plus 40€ versand, naja, schon teuer,
das sind dann quasi, na doch, sind dann 30€ pro thermostat, das wäre dann noch billiger
als in deutschland, aber dafür muss es auch aus china bestellen, dann kann ich mir für
3€ mehr auch in deutschland bestellen, quickmuffs, ah ne, keine ahnung, das muss ich mir alles
einbauen, ja ich знаю wo any
Ah doch, hast du eigentlich ein Pie-Hole und was hältst du davon?
Nix.
Ich hatte mal eins, also das ist nichts anstößiges irgendwie, das ist ein DNS-Adblocker, den
man auf dem Raspberry Pi installieren kann, also sowas, das da, hat mittlerweile jeder
größere Technik-YouTube-Channel schon einmal durch dieses Thema, das ist jetzt wirklich
nichts neues, aber ich finde es nicht brauchbar.
Das liegt daran, dass das auf den meisten Seiten tatsächlich schon ein bisschen Werbung
blockt, aber auf den wichtigen Seiten, YouTube und Twitch, blockt das keine Werbung, das
liegt daran, weil das von der Funktion her die Werbung auf Twitch und YouTube nicht zuverlässig
blocken kann.
Gerade auf YouTube nicht, YouTube macht es ganz besonders trickreich, das Ding ist nämlich
kein normaler Adblocker, wie hier sowas, was man im Browser hat, sondern was das macht
ist, das löst einfach nur Namen von bekannten Servern oder von bekannte Domains, von denen
Werbung ausgeliefert wird, löst das einfach nicht auf und dementsprechend können dann
die Anwendungen ihre Werbung nicht laden, weil sie die Werbung nicht von zentralen Ad-Servern
abrufen können.
Allerdings, Twitch und YouTube machen es jetzt so, die liefern den Content, also sprich
die Videos und die Werbung von den gleichen Servern aus, das heißt, wenn ich die blocke
in meinem Pie-Hole, dann kann ich keine Videos mehr gucken auf YouTube oder Twitch, das heißt
du kannst Twitch und YouTube nicht zuverlässig damit blocken und dementsprechend ist es für
mich ziemlich nutzlos geworden, deswegen ist es besser, man verwendet einen stinknormalen
Adblocker auf dem Desktop, kein Problem, auf dem Desktop logischerweise gibt es es für
jeden Browser, auf Android gibt es es auch für die meisten Anwendungsfälle Apps mit
Adblocker, nur unter iOS hast du ein Problem, unter iOS musst du quasi die offizielle YouTube
App und die offizielle Twitch App verwenden, es sei denn, man ist damit zufrieden, dass
man Ding über Safari die Seiten benutzt, allerdings muss man halt auch mal ehrlich sagen, YouTube
und Twitch über Safari ist auf dem iPhone deutlich nerviger als über die jeweiligen
Apps.
So und deswegen bringt das nichts aus meiner Sicht, wenn es YouTube und Twitch nicht blocken
kann, ist 90% meiner Anwendungsfälle nicht existent und es ist egal, ob es Pie-Hole ist
oder ob es Edgard ist oder ob es irgendein DNS Blocker ist, es ist vollkommen egal, DNS
basierte Adblocker können YouTube und Twitch nicht blocken, wenn sie den Content vom gleichen
Server ausliefern wie die Werbung, das geht nicht, du kannst die Domain nur auflösen
oder nicht auflösen, wenn du sie nicht auflöst, bekommst du keine Werbung, bekommst aber auch
kein Video, wenn du sie auflöst, bekommst du Video, bekommst auch Werbung, kannst du
nichts dagegen machen, das geht technisch gesehen nicht.
Ich weiß, dass es für so paar Customscripts gibt, die versuchen quasi tagesaktuell irgendwelche
Blacklists rauszuhauen, mit denen man manche Sachen vielleicht doch noch abfackeln kann,
aber im Großen und Ganzen muss man eben sagen, gerade Twitch, YouTube und alle möglichen
Seiten, die jetzt langsam aber sicher auf den Trichter gekommen sind, Werbung und Content
vom gleichen Host aus zu liefern, geht damit nicht zu blocken.
Man kann damit viele andere Sachen blocken, ja, das stimmt.
Was für mich nicht so wichtig ist, weil ich verwende Promite auf dem Android, das ist
ein Browser mit eingebautem, also ein Chromium-basierter Browser mit eingebautem Adblocker.
Auf dem Android-Tablet verwende ich auch YouTube-Vans und sonst wie gedürft es auch mit Adblocker
dabei, da habe ich das Problem nicht.
Und auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad, ja, da lasse ich mich halt mit Werbung zugleistern.
Im Safari kann man auch, ich glaube, ich habe sogar einen Adblocker im Safari, warum nutzt
du nicht Brave, keine Ahnung, habe ich mir vor zwei Jahren angeguckt, war nicht so meins.
Promite beste.
Genau, du kannst im Safari, unter iOS kannst du Adblocker installieren, aber das bringt
dir wirklich nur im Safari was, das bringt dir nichts für YouTube und Twitch, wenn man
sich über die eigene App guckt.
Auch die Kaufversion kann YouTube und Twitch nicht blocken, wenn die das versprechen, halte
ich das für gelogen.
Du kannst im Fall der Fälle nur Ads blocken, unter iOS mit diesem System Adblocker, die
über den Safari gehen, das höchste der Gefühle ist vielleicht noch Apps, die über den System
Webview gehen, wobei ich mir da auch gar nicht so sicher bin.
Aber spätestens bei der Twitch-App, bei der YouTube-App ist Schluss.
Ja, und YouTube++ und solche Sachen funktionieren bloß, wenn das iPhone jailbreak ist.
Also, YouTube++ ist glaube ich fürs Android, aber keine Ahnung, also, auf dem Android ist
kein Problem, aber auf dem iPhone sind die meisten Sachen nur mit jailbreak, und das
fällt bei meinem iPhone komplett flach, weil mein iPhone gesponsert ist von der Firma,
die beiden iPhones und die jailbreak gehe ich nicht.
Äh, du kannst hier Chat wieder aufmachen, weil ich hab's wieder zugemacht, da Basti
hat eben noch was gefragt, da muss ich noch mal was zu sagen, weil das stimmt nämlich
nicht so ganz.
Er hat gesagt, wie blockst du bitte Werbung von YouTube?
Instream-Werbung blocken ist mir nix bekannt, selbst Uplog funktioniert ja nicht, nein,
gegen Instream-Werbung, also sprich Werbung, die encoded ist in den Videocontent, den du
guckst, da kannst du nix dagegen machen.
Also wenn ich jetzt in einem Video sage, das heutige Video ist gesponsert von Raid Shadow
Legends, da kannst du nix dagegen machen, aber es gibt dazu auch schon die ersten Add-ons,
die überspringen das dann im Video.
Ich hab übrigens heute ne Anfrage bekommen für meinen Twitch-Channel, ob ich Raid Shadow
Legends zeigen will, wollt ihr die mal sehen, oder soll ich die euch mal vorlesen?
Also Basti, das funktioniert nicht, da hast du recht.
Was du machen kannst mit diesen DNS-Add-Blockern ist halt, du kannst Domains nicht auflösen,
wo Adds ausgeliefert werden, aber hier auch mit Sachen im Browser hast du vollkommen
recht, kannst du Instream-Werbung nicht blocken.
Was du blocken kannst ist die Werbung auf YouTube und Twitch, die nicht im Video encoded
ist, sondern die zwar von den gleichen Servern ausgeliefert wird, aber in irgendeiner Art
und Weise noch den Ladevorgang auf der Seite nach sich zieht.
Das können diese Sachen hier blocken, weil Browser-Add-ons haben den vollen Zugriff
auf deinen Browser, auf das ganze HTML und JavaScript-Zeug, was da läuft.
Weder ein DNS-Add-Blocker noch irgendwie ein Add-Block-Proxy oder sonst was hat Zugriff
auf dieses Zeug, was in deinem Browser drin ist.
Mit Namen ist hier so ein Ding, da gibt es schon immer, wenn ich Max sage, haben wir
allein schon 5 Stück hier wahrscheinlich.
Also ich lese euch das mal kurz vor.
Ich werde euch die Mail nicht zeigen, weil der hat seinen Discord-Nick geleakt, ich will
nicht, dass man den jetzt irgendwie belästigt oder so.
Also, Hi Wubblors, New Sponsorship Opportunity, it's nice to meet you, I'm reaching out on
behalf of, gut, das lese ich euch jetzt nicht vor, von irgendeinem komischen Marketing-Stonksladen,
so bla bla bla, Sponsorship Opportunity with the world's top RPG turn-based battler Raid
Shadow Legends.
So, das ist also, Raid Shadow Legends ist der world's top RPG turn-based battler, falls
ihr das noch nicht wusstet.
Also battler nicht wie battlen, sondern wie kämpfen.
So, und this Sponsorship offers, jetzt pass mal auf, 2 Stunden auf Sponsored Gameplay
on Twitch soll ich zeigen, and Social Media Posts, also ich soll quasi Raid Shadow Legends
2 Stunden in meinem Livestream zeigen und dafür gibt es 425 Euro.
So, und dann wollen sie noch, so, und dann kann man noch, also dann gibt es zusätzlich
noch die Möglichkeit, ich kann, was ist das hier, was wollen sie mir hiermit sagen, genau,
ich kann auch irgendwie so eine, wie nennt man das auf Deutsch, bei so einer Kampagne
mitmachen, wo man quasi sagt, Leute, wenn ihr euch registriert, dann nehmt meinen RefLink
und wenn ich so und so viele RefLink Kunden bringe, krieg ich noch mal Geld und sowas
in der Richtung.
So, und sie schreiben, man kann bis zu 1500 Dollar mit diesem Sponsorship machen.
Wenn ich Interesse hab, soll ich ihn auf Discord adden, er wird laufen mit mir zu chatten und
natürlich würde er auch noch gerne weitere Additional Sponsorship Opportunities mir
offerieren.
Ja, so siehts aus.
Aber ich find's witzig, dass ich mittlerweile sogar Mails für Wubblos bekomme und nicht
nur für YouTube.
Also man kann mit Sicherheit noch ein bisschen mehr rausholen, aber mal ganz davon abgesehen,
also Raid Shadow Legends ist, glaube ich, eines der letzten Dinge, die ich promoten
will.
Das muss wirklich nicht sein, Raid Shadow Legends, ne, echt nicht.
Könntest du mal Body Pillows promoten?
Ja, mach ich, gute Idee, Kiyokun.
Wir machen zu Weihnachten, machen wir ein Keks Body Pillow und das promoten wir dann.
So, was muss ich noch kaufen, genau, also das Hammer, das Hammer, das Hammer.
So, ich will mir noch einen Aquara Sensor und zwar einen, weil ich ein bisschen das
ganze Zigbee Zeug ausprobieren will, will ich mir hiervon noch einkaufen.
Gibt's den, gibt's den vielleicht auch lieferbar?
Ein Vibration Sensor.
Oh, okay, ne, für 19 Euro kaufe ich mir das nicht, ist mir zu teuer.
Gut, hat sich gerade erledigt, kaufe ich nicht.
Dachte mir, das ist eine super Gelegenheit, mal ein bisschen die ganze Zigbee Geschichte
weiter auszuprobieren.
Also Busty IV, das ist, erscheint mir ein bisschen viel.
Ich hab von angeboten, im 5-stelligen Bereich gehört 4SL Basis, also ganz ehrlich, 5-stelliger
Bereich bedeutet ja 10.000 plus, das ist unrealistisch für einen Streamer in meiner
Größe.
Also ich kenn ja so ein bisschen die Preise, was so Ads-Sachen und so auf YouTube angeht
noch, und da bekommste zwar auch, sagen wir mal, höhere 4-stellige Beträge manchmal
geboten, aber 5-stellig hat mir persönlich auf YouTube auch noch keiner was geboten,
weil ich bin ja auch auf YouTube jetzt keiner mit Millionen-Abos, ich hab ja nur 270.000
Abos und aktuell mach ich ja noch nicht mal was, aber selbst in der Zeit, wo das bei mir
voll angesagt war auf YouTube, also 5-stellig hat mir noch nie jemand was geboten, 4-stellig
schon öfters und auch ein bisschen höheres 4-stelliges auch schon öfters und ich hab
auch ein paar Sachen gemacht, die 4-stellig waren, aber 5-stellig nicht.
Nein, und G2A war auch nicht 5-stellig, G2A war immer nur überlegen, ich hab keine Ahnung
mehr ehrlich gesagt, was ich bei G2A verdient hab.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich bei G2A, 1.000 Euro oder so, ich glaub so um die 1.000 Euro
hab ich bei G2A gekriegt für Promotion im Video und Reflinks verteilen.
So irgendwie in dem Dreh, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig gut dran erinnern ehrlich
gesagt.
Die beste Promotion-Geschichte, die einfachste, die jeder machen kann, sind Amazon Reflinks.
Venise Unleashed, klar hab ich schon gehört, da bin ich auch äußerst gespannt drauf,
es wäre cool, also ich würd's denen echt wünschen, dass das abhebt im Dezember und
richtig viele Spieler hat und dazu führt, dass Battlefield 3 wieder mehr gespielt wird
und vor allem Battlefield 3 diesmal mit Modding-Support, das ist natürlich richtig poggers und es wäre
nicht das erste Mal, dass ein Mod beliebter wird als das Hauptspiel, ich sag mal nur Counter
Strike zum Beispiel, allerdings sind die Parallelen, da hören sie auch schon auf,
weil Counter Strike war ein Mod für ein Spiel, was eines der besten modbaren Spiele aller
Zeiten ist, nämlich Half-Life 1, also auch für den damaligen Zeit, Mods und Half-Life
1 war ja so ein Ding, das war wie gemacht füreinander und Mods und Battlefield 3 ist halt absolut
nicht gemacht füreinander, das hat der Hutz eigentlich auch schon wieder auf, die Parallelen.
Gibt es eigentlich dieses neue Raspberry Pi, dieses neue Raspberry Pi Case mit dem Argon
2 oder wie das hieß, Argon 1 M2 hieß das, genau, das fand ich nämlich eine richtig
nice Geschichte, gibt es das hier schon zu kaufen, nein, gibt es das irgendwo in Deutschland
zu kaufen, wahrscheinlich nicht, ah doch hier, wow 63 Euro, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich gebe
doch keine 63 Euro für den Case aus, wo der Raspberry Pi genauso viel kostet, ihr seid
doch nicht mal ganz bei Sinn, ich mein 26 Euro ist schon ein stattlicher Preis für
den Raspberry Pi Case, aber das sehe ich nicht ein, ja eigentlich macht das Gehäuse gar
nicht so besonderes im Vergleich zum ersten, also das ist es absolut nicht wert, das ist
total hängen geblieben.
Das schöne daran ist halt, dass die ganzen, hallo, Bilder, gibt keine ordentlichen Bilder
davon, die haben die Ausgänge beispielsweise hinten rausgeführt und die Kühlung ist auch
ganz okay, aber das wird sich im Leben nicht lohnen, da 60 Euro für auszugeben, das ist
komplett overpriced, das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht, wenn man ein günstiges gutes Raspberry
Pi Gehäuse will, kann man sich entweder das da kaufen, wenn es ein bisschen größer sein
soll oder man kauft sich das hier, die Flick Case oder so, wie heißt das, Flick Case, hier
ist das da oder man kauft sich das, das ist auch okay, das ist ein Gehäuse aus Aluminium
und die benutzen quasi das komplette Gehäuse als Passivkühler, so, also wenn ich ein günstiges
Gehäuse suchen würde, was auch noch halbwegs gut ausschaut, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
das hier nehmen, ja, aber entweder das, was, Argon, was sagt der Serious Max Neo, das kenne
ich glaube ich gar nicht, ach doch, doch, doch, doch, klar kenne ich das, das ist auch
nicht übel, ja, aber ich würde nie, also 15 Euro für einen ordentlichen großen Klotz
Metall als Passivkühler ist okay, aber mehr würde ich da auch nicht für ausgeben, das
hier ist schon eigentlich viel zu teuer, viel zu teuer, man muss es ja auch nicht übertreiben,
weil eines der großen Vorteile von dieser ganzen, von diesem ganzen Raspberry Pi Ökosystem
ist ja, dass das preisleistungsmäßig immer in ganz guten Regionen liegt und das hat jetzt
ja keinen Sinn, wenn ich die ganze Raspberry-Pi-Geschichte so aufbohre, dass ich mir auch einen Stromsparen
des Einstiegs X86-Board mit RAM kaufen könnte, hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn, äh, Speider,
keine Ahnung, das habe ich mir nicht angeguckt, ja, genau, Basri, das ist, das ist das Gehäuse,
das ist USB auf, ähm, M2, aber das ist zu teuer, das, das, das geht noch in Ordnung
hier.
Ja, und der Raspberry Pi an sich ist nach wie vor für so Bastelsachen das Beste, was
es gibt und das liegt einfach daran, dass der Community Support der Beste ist von allen,
also sprich, du findest so viel fertige Tutorials von Raspberry Pi, Videos, Content zum Raspberry
Pi und auch der Support, die ganze Raspian-Geschichte ist einfach astrein, da kannst du nichts sagen
und der Raspberry Pi, das kommt ja noch dazu, hat 30.000 verschiedene Addon-Möglichkeiten,
was, äh, Heads und Boards und Sachen angeht und das Wichtigste eigentlich, der Raspberry
Pi ist ziemlich günstig, also die ganzen China-Alternativen mögen zwar ein bisschen
billiger sein oder mögen ein bisschen leistungsfähiger sein oder sonst was, aber denen fehlt irgendwas,
was der Raspberry Pi hat, sei es Community Support, Treiber, Support, ähm, Betriebssystem,
Geschichten, Tutorials, ähm, so dass es sich nicht lohnt für 2,50€ weniger und was immer
noch gut ist, es lohnt sich heute auch noch einen Raspberry Pi 3 zu kaufen, weil der Raspberry
Pi 3 reicht für die meisten Anwendungen wirklich dicke aus, der Unterschied ist jetzt nicht
die Welt, der einzige Unterschied ist, wenn man viel RAM braucht, also wenn man, ähm,
sag mal mal einen Gigabyte, äh, 4 Gigabyte RAM oder 2, 4, 8 Gigabyte RAM braucht, dann
muss es ein Raspberry Pi 4 sein, aber mal ganz ehrlich, welche Anwendungen auf ein Raspberry
Pi brauchen so viel RAM, die man auch sinnvoll auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen hat, da gibt's
nicht so viele.
Einen Rock Pi hatte ich noch nie in den Fingern gehabt, aber ich hab einen, einen Odroid HC2,
das ist der gleiche Chip da drauf und der hat auch ziemlich an Treiber- und Betriebssystemsupport
gekrankt.
Also ich finde, wenn jemand sich einen Raspberry Pi kaufen will, ist preisleistungsmäßig
ein Raspberry Pi 3 aktuell das beste, was er sich kaufen kann.
Ja, ESX ist auch eine Spielerei, die ist ja nicht sinnvoll zu, sinnvoll, Sachen kann
man damit ja auf dem Raspberry Pi nicht wirklich machen.
Also so ein Raspberry Pi 3 ist, wie gesagt, ich denke nach wie vor das beste Einstiegsding,
was man sich kaufen kann davon.
Top Treiber-Support, tausende, hunderttausende Blogposts, Tutorials, Videos, zig Zusatz-Hardware,
es gibt nichts, was es nicht gibt für einen Raspberry Pi, das ist das beste, was man sich
kaufen kann.
Also ich würde sogar, preisleistungsmäßig, wenn ich es aufs Budget gucken muss, würde
ich das einem Raspberry Pi 4 vorziehen.
Na ja, guck mal, der kostet 35 Euro und der Einstiegs Raspberry Pi kostet 60 Euro, ne,
das ist das 4 Gigabyte Modell, 41, naja gut, ok, ich nehme es zurück, der Unterschied ist
doch nicht so hoch, aber du brauchst da noch ein Netzteil für den Raspberry Pi 3, den
kannst du zur Not noch an einem USB Kabel und einem USB Stecker betreiben, zwar nicht
unter Volllast, aber es funktioniert, der Raspberry Pi 4 ist dich permanent am anmeckeln,
dass er zu wenig Strom kriegt.
Also ich, gerade auch diese Komplett-Pucks sind recht attraktiv und er bleibt deutlich
kühler als ein Raspberry Pi 4, kommt auch noch dabei.
Ja, also ich würde immer noch sagen, wer was budgetmäßiges zum Einsteigen sucht, ist
mit dem Raspberry Pi 3 immer noch gut dabei.
Ja, wie bin ich jetzt da drauf gekommen?
Also ich hab noch am Case geguckt, wo ich gerade beim Nachgucken bin, wie sieht es denn
mit 4TB Samsung NVMe aus, gibt es die mittlerweile?
Nein.
Aber wann gibt es denn 4TB Samsung NVMe?
Haben die da schon irgendwie einen Release Date?
Nö.
Nutzt du eigentlich auch Arduino?
Wenn du Arduino in Form der Libraries meinst, ja, ziemlich viel, wenn du Arduino in Form
von wirklich der echten Original Arduino Hardware meinst, dann hab ich keinen im Einsatz, ne.
Ich benutze nur ESP32 und ESP266 und nach Möglichkeit eigentlich nur noch ESP32.
Nein, kenn ich keinen.
Was bei AliExpress gibt es da schon?
Ja, bei AliExpress findest du wahrscheinlich 4TB NVMe SSDs, die in Wirklichkeit 512G haben
und sich als 4TB melden.
Ja, Blitzwolf, wer möchte nicht gerne eine Blitzwolf SSD haben?
Nee, das ist ja nur ein Einschub.
Das gab vor Jahren mal so einen 2TB, wie gesagt, ich sag vor Jahren, das heißt es schon ein
bisschen her, 2TB USB Stick aus China für irgendwie 8 Euro oder so und in Wirklichkeit
hatte der 512MB und hat im Prinzip immer im Kreis geschrieben, also sprich, wenn der,
der hat, also erstens hat er nicht schnell geschrieben und zweitens hat er quasi vorne
wieder angefangen zu schreiben, wenn er hinten fertig war.
Das war quasi ein Ring-Buffer in Hardware-Form, der 2TB USB Stick, da hat sich gemeldet mit
2TB, du konntest da auch 2TB drauf schreiben, wolltest du aber 2TB wieder lesen, ging das
nicht.
Also maximal 512MB, na gut, was willst du denn sonst erwarten für ein 8TB USB Stick,
das war hier, 2TB Iron Man USB Stick, ja und er war auch wirklich im Iron Man Design, hier,
lol.
Wish, Wish, Alter, warum kauft man sich sowas, man merkt doch jetzt schon, man weiß doch
von Anfang an, dass es Scam ist, ist das, ist das Fake G-Bait Video, das ist doch, meint
er das ernst, das ist doch, das ist doch G-Bait, ich mein, er hat halt einen komischen Mac
am Start, aber kann ich mal ordentlich aufnehmen, ey, man erkennt doch nix, so scheiße, ok,
das muss G-Bait sein, so blöd kann man nicht sein, das kann man nicht ernstbein, was ist
das auch noch für ein Hintergrund, also entweder ist der Typ einfach nur total bescheuert oder
es ist Fake, um die Leute dazu zu bringen, dass man ihn kauft.
That's insane, ja, was ein Schwachsinn, das ist wirklich, Leute, gibt ihr das glauben,
ich fass es nicht.
Übrigens, der Sebaro hat letztens was neues, was gepostet im Discord, was ich erstmal interessant
fand, also ihr wisst ja, dass ich so einen Odroid HC2 im Einsatz hab, das ist quasi
ein Single Board Computer mit SATA Anschluss, den hab ich drüben liegen im Wohnzimmer mit
einer SSD dran und hier ist ein TV Stick dran mit Dual Tuner, der legt drüben im Wohnzimmer
und macht Aufnahmen vom Fernseher und streamt dann zum Shield TV und sowas, eigentlich ein
ganz cooles Gerät und auch ziemlich günstig, passt alles wunderbar und jetzt sind die auf
die Idee gekommen, Ice Freak, 12 Monate schon, huge, das ist ja schon, sehr nice, Dankeschön,
so und jetzt sind die auf die Idee gekommen bei dem Hersteller zu sagen, ey, also das
Ding, finde ich, sieht auch ganz passabel aus, weil man dreht das ja auch, ich muss euch
mal das Bild davon zeigen, man dreht das ja auch andersrum, also man sieht schon hier,
dass der Hersteller einen Hang dazu hat, hässliche Gehäuse zu verkaufen, so und was man macht
ist, man, wusste gar nicht, dass es den alleine gibt, man macht hier eine Festplatte rein und
dreht das Ding um und dann sieht das tatsächlich ganz passabel aus, aber irgendwie dreht das
keiner um, hier, genau, also, man macht das hier rein und dann dreht man es einfach um
und dann hat man so einen schwarzen Kühlblock da in der Ecke liegen, das fällt im Wohnzimmer
in der Ecke nicht weiter auf, also das ist eigentlich ganz cool, so und, also ich hab
es allein schon aus dem Grund umgedreht, weil ich nicht wollte, dass die Katze hier irgendwie
dann drauf rumläuft oder so, so und jetzt sind die auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
einen Billignass zu bauen und das sieht dermaßen kacke aus und dermaßen wackelig und dermaßen
mies, dass ich mich frage, wer sich das ausgedacht hat, ja auf Golem, mach hinne, ich mein, ernsthaft,
the fuck, das sieht aus wie ein AliExpress Billig Experiment, was soll das sein, soll
ich der Sache meine Daten wirklich anvertrauen, das sieht aus, als hätte ich das gebastelt
daheim, mit einem 3D Drucker und einem ESP32, es sieht so scheiße aus, so wackelig scheiße
sieht das aus, ich würde im Leben nicht aufkommen, da irgendwelche wichtigen Daten drauf zu
hauen, weiß nicht, ob es bessere Bilder davon irgendwo gibt, ich mein, das sieht so, so,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das beschütze, was ich dazu sagen soll, so gewollt und nicht
gekonnt aus, das könnte ein Toaster sein, genau, das könnte ein Toaster sein, also ganz
frischbar mies, das sieht aus wie so ein do it yourself Bastelprojekt, was ich daheim
zusammengebaut habe, so, wie man das verkaufen kann, ist mir komplett schleierhaft, was kostet
der Spaß, wird wahrscheinlich auch so um die 50 Euro kosten oder so, also ohne Platten,
ja 65 Euro, das ist preislich gar nicht so schlecht, 65 Euro für so einen Single Board
Computer mit zwei SATA Ports, das ist schon in Ordnung, 65 Euro, aber es sieht so unglaublich
scheiße aus, dass die dir schon Schmerzensgeld bezahlen müssen dafür, dass du das überhaupt
nimmst, also die 65 Euro sind mindestens 100 Euro, weil es so scheiße aussieht, also die
müssten dir wirklich noch Schmerzensgeld dafür bezahlen, Leute ich sehs grad, es ist 22 Uhr,
ich bin jetzt gar nicht dazu gekommen, alles einzukaufen, eine Sache, ich brauch noch ne
neue Packung, ich hab echt, ich hab nen Jumperkabel verbraucht, das ist echt immer feierlich hier,
das Set geht immer, wunderbar, add, so, Bas, die EW du hast recht, das würd ich der Sache
vorziehen, dann würd ich lieber ne Docking Station kaufen und USB 3 irgendwo anders
ran anschließen, halt nicht unbedingt an Raspberry Pi, weil Raspberry Pi ist halt nach wie vor
keine gute Grundlage für ne NAS, im Raspberry Pi fehlt eines der wichtigsten Features für
ne NAS, nämlich Crypto Extensions oder eben ne halbwegs schnelle CPU, was das im Zweifelsfall
auch in Software machen kann, deswegen finde ich taugt der Raspberry Pi als NAS nichts,
und ich geh mal davon aus, dass der Raspberry Pi sogar bei normalen Geschichten an seine
Grenzen geraten wird, also wenn man zum Beispiel sagt, ok, ich mach da jetzt, ich hab ja schon
ein Gehäuse für den Raspberry Pi gesehen mit vier SATA Ports, so, geh mal wirklich
davon aus, ich mach nen Raspberry Pi, ich mach das dran und stöpsel da irgendwie 14
Terabyte Platten dran, mach da irgendwie nen ZFS RAID 5 drauf, also nen ZFS RAID 1, starte
nen Samba und kopier was drüber, ich bin mir da sogar relativ sicher, dass IO, Paritätsberechnung,
ZFS Checksum und Samba der Raspberry Pi nicht mit Gigabit abgefackelt bekommt.
Nee, RAM ist ok, das Ding hat bis zu 8 Gigabyte RAM, das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, 8 Gigabyte
RAM reicht dicke, ach Quatsch, 1 Gigabyte pro Terabyte, das ist, das ist FreeNAS Forums
Blödsinn, das stimmt nicht, du brauchst kein Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte, das sagen manche
ZFS Big Brains sagen das, aber man muss sich den Kontext angucken, der Kontext ist, wenn
man sicherstellen möchte, dass das in einem Enterprise NAS Umfeld mit mehreren parallelen
Benutzer und sag mal konstantem Workload performant funktionieren soll.
Dann lass ich mir das gefallen, wenn jemand sagt ZFS 1 Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte, aber
wir reden hier von einem Heimanwender mit maximal, selbst wenn es eine Familie ist mit
zwei Kindern, mit maximal zwei gleichzeitig Benutzern und keinen großartigen Performance
Ansprüchen, wo es hier irgendwie mit 10 Gigabit Schnittstelle oder sonst was geht.
Nee, also diese zwei, ja du hast Recht, die sagen, das wird gerne gesagt bei ZFS, aber
das ist Blödsinn, im Heimbereich ist ZFS komplett normal benutzbar, auch mit 4 oder
8 Gigabyte RAM, also das ist kein Ding.
Braucht man heute überhaupt noch ein NAS, naja gut, wo willst du dein Zeug sonst drauf
speichern, wenn das im Netzwerk geschert haben willst, man kann es natürlich eine USB Festplatte
im Kreis tragen, hat, hat das, hat der Pi Compute, hat der Krypto Extensions, hat der
Krypto, also ansonsten taugt er nämlich genauso wenig wie ein normaler Raspberry Pi 4 dafür.
Nur wenn er Krypto Extensions hat bringt das was, nee, wenn er es nicht hat ist es als
NAS auch nicht zu gebrauchen, wie gesagt NAS Hardware ohne Krypto Extensions ist eigentlich
ziemlich sinnlos und wie gesagt die CPU reicht ja auch nicht dafür.
Gut, wenn man mit Cloud Sync auskommt für ein paar Sachen, dann braucht man kein NAS,
das ist halt anwendungsspezifisch, also ich hab beispielsweise meine ganzen Gameplayaufnahmen
immer aufs NAS geschoben.
Gameplay aufgenommen auf der SSD, dass es keine Slowdowns gibt und dann einmal am Tag
aufs NAS geschoben.
Was sagst du zu dieser Kiste, ich hab hier einen Low Power, einen Intel Low Power x86
Kiste, die hat einen Samba Server drauf, also für Windows Shares, einen Wiki und ein Heimautomatisierungskram.
Also das ist kein NAS im eigentlichen Sinne, dass man sagt hey das ist nur für Storage
da, das ist halt ein Linux Server mit eine SSD und eine 12TB Platte dran mit einem Samba
Server drauf installiert, wo man halt auch als NAS verwenden kann.
Aber sonst großartige NAS Funktionen wie irgendein Webinterface oder andere Sachen hat das nicht.
Das ist eigentlich meine Heimautomatisierungskiste, aber nachdem da eine 12TB Platte dran ist,
hab ich da ein Samba drauf installiert und gut ist.
Ich hab hier schon stark downgraded, vorher hatte ich diese Kiste hier, vorher hatte ich
ja diese Kiste hier, ja ja, Max alles gut, ah ne, das ist ja der ganz alte, lull das
ist ja das ganz alte, Moment, Moment, Moment, äh, hier das da, ja, äh die 4AE Kiste hatte
ich, die hatte einen ZFS 1er Raid, also einen Raid 5 mit ZFS über 13TB Platten, das war
vollkommen oversized das Ding, das hab ich mir eigentlich mal gekauft für, oder zusammengebaut
besser gesagt, für Spielereien mit Grafikkarten durchreichen und sonst was, total oversized,
übelst krass Performance für die Zeit damals gehabt, mit 8 CPU Kern und aktuellen Intel
Belegern damals drinne, wie gesagt 2017 war das richtig, richtig nice, aber das hab ich
ähm, wieder, wieder außer Betrieb genommen, erstens, weil es ein viel zu großer Single
Point of Failure war, ich hab hier mehr oder weniger alles drüber laufen lassen, was
es gibt, dass ich konnte nicht mal mehr die Rollos runter machen, im Zweifelsfall, wenn
die Kiste ausgefallen ist und es hat mir auch ein bisschen zu viel Strom gebraucht.
Um jetzt mal hier was zu zu sagen, was gerade einer im Chat geschickt hat, ja von der Leistung
her reicht das auf jeden Fall, für so ziemlich alles was du machen willst, aber musst halt
mal gucken, was das für ein Stromverbrauch hat, also die Hardware ist definitiv schon
älter, wenn es DDR3 ist und die Dinger sind halt nicht auf Stromverbrauch ausgelegt, also
das kann durchaus sein, dass das irgendwie 200 Watt frisst, Eidl, ich hab echt keine
Ahnung was es frisst, aber das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie nicht sparsam
sind, die sind laut und stromfressend, so und ein Intel NUC kann man sich nur kaufen, wenn
man kein PCI Express will, ich hab mir diese Low Power, ich hab ja wie gesagt, ich hab's
ja schon ein paar mal gezeigt, ich hab hier dieses Board drinnen, das kostet 70 Euro
oder so, easy, wobei ich nicht exakt dieses Board habe, sondern leicht andere Konfiguration,
weil ich PCI Express haben wollte für eine 10G Netzwerkkarte, deswegen hab ich auch nicht
dieses Board, sondern das mit dem normalen großen PCI Anschluss, so das sind 10G Netzwerkkarte
drinne und es braucht Eidl jetzt mit der Netzwerkkarte 12 Watt gerade, ja 12,5 irgendwas, da kannst
du dich echt nicht beschweren und allein schon die 10G Netzwerkkarte braucht 4,5 Watt alleine,
das Ding ist wirklich verdammt Strom sparen, diese Low Power Intel Dinger, wie gesagt,
ich hab übelst downgraded bei mir daheim, die Dinger sind wirklich gut, die Mikroserver,
die sind wirklich nice, wenn man so braucht, wenn man die Leistung braucht, wenn man die
Leistung braucht und wenn man ein bisschen Geld ausgeben möchte, die sind wirklich cool,
ich weiß nicht wie gut die aktuelle Version ist, nee es gibt von AMD nichts Vergleichbares,
nicht in diesem Ultra Low Power Low Cost Segment, die Dinger sind wirklich nice, ich weiß nicht
wie gut die aktuellen sind, als die noch ein bisschen mehr würfelförmiger waren, waren
die sehr angesagt, reicht ein Raspberry Pi 3 um Daten zu speichern als nass, es sollen
nur Dokumente und ein paar Fotos hochgeladen werden, ja das reicht, aber wie gesagt, ich
bin kein Fan vom Raspberry Pi als nass, aber wenn du wirklich nur mit sagen wir mal maximal
20 MB da ein bisschen Fotos und Dokumente hochladen willst, dann reicht ein Raspberry
Pi, aber ich kann dir jetzt schon sagen, dass wenn du anfängst damit wirst du auch nach
und nach so das verlangen, verspüren, dass es schneller geht oder dass du auch mal Dateien,
die was weiß ich Videos, die irgendwie 2-3 Gigabyte groß sind aufs nass schiebst oder
wenn du sogar RAW Fotos hast, wo ja ein einzelnes Bild schon fragt mich nicht, 3 Gigabyte groß
ist, dann wird dir der Raspberry Pi schlicht und ergreifend zu langsam sein, du kriegst
da maximal 20-25, wenn es hoch kommt 30 MB die Sekunde drüber, ich würde mir eher so
mit 20 MB 25 MB rechnen und da kopierst du schon ein bisschen, also der Raspberry Pi
3 ist eigentlich noch schlechteres Nasssystem als der 4er, aber ja, wenn du wirklich nur
ganz wenig Ansprüche daran hast, Apple Care 98 und dich das nicht stört, dann geht das,
aber ich würde es nicht machen, hol dir lieber sowas hier, hol dir lieber sowas hier, da
kannst du direkt eine Festplatte dran machen und der schafft zumindest Gigabit auszulasten,
machst eine SSD dran, 2 TB SSD, flutscht 120 MB die Sekunde, du musst doch keine SSD
dran machen, Schwachsinn, hör nicht auf mich, hol dir eine ordentliche Festplatte 120 MB
die Sekunde, kein Problem, du hast natürlich keine Backup Möglichkeiten, weil nur eine
Platte, ja der Pi 4 hat Gigabit, aber der Pi 4 hat erstens keine Krypto Extensions
und die CPU ist total schwach, also was du mit dem Pi 4 machen kannst ist eine Platte
dran hängen und dann einfach ohne irgendwas, ohne Verschlüsselung, ohne Raid, ohne alles
da über deinen Fileshare was kopieren, das geht, ja, aber trotzdem, also wenn man ein
ordentliches Nass haben will, da gehört für mich erstens Verschlüsselung, Vollverschlüsselung,
also die Möglichkeit es voll zu verschlüsseln dabei, das ist also eines der essenziellsten
Sachen bei einem Nass, allein schon mit dem Hinblick, dass man die Festplatte einfach
wegschmeißen kann, ohne sich Gedanken machen zu müssen, also für mich ist Vollverschlüsselung
auf dem Nass eines der wichtigsten Features, gerade auch im Hinblick dessen, wenn die Festplatte
rumspackt, dass ich sie einfach nehmen kann und in den Müll schmeißen kann, was man machen
kann, wenn die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt ist, weil da muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen
um nichts, so was ist das, Nass mit ZFS also, ja den Mirror kannst du vielleicht noch machen,
den Mirror kannst du vielleicht noch machen, aber Performance Wunder sollte man jetzt
hier auch nicht erwarten, Encryption kannst du schon wieder komplett vergessen, also ich
finde es ist keine gute Lösung, alle Raspberry Pi Nass Sachen die ich bisher gesehen habe
sind so Krücken, die entweder keine Krypto, also die entweder keine Verschlüsselung können
richtig oder die andere Probleme haben, also Raspberry Pi mit vollverschlüsselten Platten
geht nicht, ist das Ding einfach nicht für ausgelegt, es sei denn man kommt mit 30 MB
die Sekunde klar, also wenn einem 30 MB die Sekunden reichen ist okay, kann man machen,
aber ich gehe jetzt aber von aus, wenn man eine Gigabit hat und Gigabit ist ja auch schon
ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen, dass man dann mindestens mal auch seine 100 120 MB
die Sekunde haben möchte, wenn man mit 20 30 MB die Sekunde auskommt, dann kann man
auch einen Raspberry Pi nehmen, da irgendwie ein USB Ding dran fuddeln, ZFS Rate oder Verschlüsselung
Gedöns drauf machen, noch ein Software Rate drüber und gut ist, funktionieren tut es,
aber schnell ist was anderes, so Leute, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett, wir sehen uns, wir brauchen
noch Outro Song, ich weiß, Topics beides ist okay, selber bauen oder irgendwas fertiges
kaufen, beides in Ordnung, wobei die billigen Cynology Dinge jetzt auch nicht viel mehr
Performance haben als so ein, also ich habe hier die gleiche Hardware drin, die haben wahrscheinlich
auch irgendeinen Low Cost Intel CPU drinne, mehr Performance als ein Raspberry Pi haben
wir also auf jeden Fall. So, bis denn, machts gut, CU.